[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans welcome back to st.
Louis for the final round of play in the
2019 st. Louis norm Congress I'm Ben
Simon joined as always by Grand Master
in residence
Alexander Lenderman and today we are
gonna crown champions in our Grand
Master and international master norm
groups let's take a look at our
standings whoa my voice just left
standings in our top section here two
players still in the running
playing in separate games one of them
has already ended Denis burrows comes
into the round ahead by half a point and
Jack's timkuli act with six points Boros
has since drawn his game let's look at
our standings in the IM norm section
where three players all the
International masters are in contention
for the top prize one of the games has
ended and two of the opponents Kira and
Rosen are actually playing each other
right now if we need to go to a playoff
this afternoon we will do so it will be
at 4 p.m. Central time and it will be a
best-of to rapid match game in ten with
a two second delay if it's still tied
after that we're going to go tweed blitz
arm again but I don't think we're gonna
get to any of that because it looks like
it's gonna be decided in regulation hit
us up in the YouTube chat at hat head
with hashtag norm Congress as well on
Twitter I'm in the YouTube chat right
now where's Maurice Ashley well he's not
here
but you can see him for the grand chest
tour later on more on that later
ok round 9 pairings let's do it
grandmaster norm section let's see which
games are the ones to watch Joel bonala
vs. Casa Corley that one is still in
progress
Tata abrahama and Brian Escalante that
is a draw Joel but now hardly through
pardon me the first game was a draw the
second game is a draw the third game
Brandon Jacobson versus Justin Wang that
game is still in progress and our two
key matchups Boros versus boris versus
Ali Miranda has already ended in a draw
which makes
Andrew Hong and Jack shouldn't bully act
our sole key matchup still remaining now
if Jack scores anything even a draw he
wins this field outright actually Boris
wins the field outright if Jack doesn't
win so Jack needs to win to tie and make
it to a playoff pardon me I'm not off to
a good start let's take a look at this
first game here rose versus yeah so
actually all you had this let's go to
the GM okay okay that's fine yeah so
let's take a look first up the game
between Andrew Hong and Jacques Stamboul
iakh and well this has been a very sharp
game so far and this was started with
the French the mainline and black played
to the line with gtx f6 which is obvious
a double-edged line for a fight which
makes sense and Andrew Hong also played
a relatively fighting line putting the
bridge span of three trying to
neutralize this it looks to me that
black has is already a good position out
of the opening after ninety three ninety
seven so after a couple of more normal
moves you know it's actually a
relatively quiet position here because
both sides Castle queenside so which
means it could be potentially a long
game but now Jack went for very
interesting but double edged moves c5
which allows the move Knight b5 and now
you have to either go Queen B H which is
what Jack did or you can play it even
more interesting 27 with the idea being
after takes the poor King ba to the
knight gets trapped it was possible that
that was that move was better and that
Queen b8 was played Queen c3 maybe here
takes takes Knight g5 was an interesting
option perhaps it was better but he
played Queen C 394 and this move I also
am not sure about it looks like if black
wanted to play a relatively quiet
position he could have traded and traded
Queens but of course you know this is
not what Jack wanted because he already
probably by this point
knew that he probably needed to win the
game so Jack played for 94 play for some
complications but now after this Bush 64
it's possible that Jack missed blacks
next move I mean Jack missed White's
next move which is d5 and something this
move is very very nasty move because if
for example if you take this f3 and
suddenly the bishop is trapped and even
d4 doesn't really help because you can
just take that and because of pins all
over the place the white ends up being
on top here likewise if you take with
the bishop Vidal has another very nice
tactic here
does anyone see it if you don't you can
pause the video but it is rook takes d5
and it turns out if you take with the
pawn that loses the bishop and after
that you know you basically get made in
short order as well and rook takes d5
removal removes the guard of this rook
on h8 as well so perhaps black either
missed or underestimated to move d5 or
maybe he was banking on the move h6 but
at least it looks like after d6 another
strong intermediate move you have to
take because bishop f8 then you just
lose the the rook actually you don't
lose the rope because of this move
let's check but you can play Knight g5
first and then there's also lots of
problems here
so black ended up taking but here we are
in with this position where it looks
like if anyone can win it's more likely
white white is the one who's kind of in
control black has to be in the defense
of his king is weak why has the
initiative so objectively speaking white
should be happy with I mean objectively
speaking black should be kind of happy
with equalizing this position but of
course for Jack I'm sure Wang will not
be good enough because he needs to win
the game so get into the playoff against
Danish morose indeed and so yeah like I
said as a correction before yes indeed
Jack does need to win to force a playoff
against barouche that would be a wrap
match later this afternoon so let's take
a look at our pairings in our I am norm
section you know nor no norms at stake
in either section anymore but that's
what we'll still call it Gauri Shankar
versus Aaron grab its key that game is
still in progress Aaron Aaron Jacobsen
versus Kenta chiku rate' Rochelle Wu
versus Peter Gennaro's and two games
that have actually finished toxic with
corruption and the erosion car just
recently did win against Aaron Grubb in
skis so unfortunately for Aaron his
votes in this tournament continued right
very tough tournament for him all right
please pardon us everyone we're off to a
very very rocky start on my part that is
exclusively my fault but our key matchup
is affected by Torres as black drawing
Ezra chambers it is now down to these
two guys Eric Rosen and Keaton Kyra and
Eric is trying to get into a playoff
situation with a victory
is it possible Alex it's very very
unlikely basically he's in a one down
end game where I mean basically he
should be fighting for a draw but of
course a miracle can always happen I
mean it looks like his chances actually
did improve because he could actually
try to get the spawn all the way to b5
and then you kind of never know I mean
if the point somehow goes further then
there's maybe a smidgen of hope of
course the fact that white even got this
far is already very nice accomplishment
for him because earlier on it looked
really really bleak um so but this was
actually a game with chances for both
sides so let's take a look at how the
game played out it started with the
relativity close Sicilian which makes
sense to play because away from Theory
not forcing things trying to keep some
pieces on the board and it looks like
white got a relatively comfortable game
but something later was going a bit
wrong here black is still fine because
the d4 squares in control but somewhere
later on it looked like Eric made a few
inaccuracies
yeah so this whole thing that you went
for with f5
it looks very ambitious but it probably
is just a wrong idea because even though
you get there Foursquare but now you
give up the d4 square and suddenly this
mission becomes very strong the d5
square is easily neutralized by this
bishop and also just loses the pawn so
in fact there's a 5 was just probably
very pretty mature and if white wanted
to play something you probably wanted to
play Knight c3 and maybe control this
square somehow or maybe even start with
this and then there's not sure if that
was helpful but in any event f5
definitely seemed like it was just too
premature maybe black is kind of ok
anyway but this looks like just kind of
white going very desperate here and now
black is just a pawn
with an attack and you know in this
position black is completely winning you
know black can play above like rook b8
go 94 up a pawn White has a weak King
black started playing a few inaccuracies
at some point like maybe here even rook
c8 was somehow a bit stronger first and
then rocha for but he went for g4 which
allowed at least the Queen trade now you
know it's it made sense to do that
because you know you'd think black has
no risk here but at the same time you
know blacks
winning chance is minimized here and now
this is kind of a more difficult
technical position black is still having
an extra pawn and here black still is
probably winning with this very nice
idea rook e8 King did soo and a very
nice move rook III with idea after this
you just take here and after this you
take here and I believe rookie 3 is kind
of he has to go to h3 now but now after
Knight takes and Russia 3 you're gonna
probably win at some point the second
form and basically it's winning for
block but instead he took on g1 right
away so probably played it a bit quickly
and then now he's in this position which
is still gonna be a very difficult task
ahead of him
a difficult technical task white here
played before and black played this
should be five and I would say still
Black has fair amount of waiting chances
but of course now even white can maybe
dream of some fantastic scenario where
the spawn just you know it becomes a
Cinderella but still it's very early to
fantasize about the possibility of white
winning in objectively speaking white
it's still fighting for a draw but of
course as we know in chests anything can
happen what would Eric having five
minutes and Keaton 32 minutes and black
just being okay with a draw it still
doesn't seem very likely but of course
in chess you never know right so we have
Luis Torres sitting at six points we
have Eric Rosen fighting to get there
here at at six points so Kyra can is the
only player who can win this out right
at this moment with any score that is
what I'm going to say all right let's
take a look at our prizes first of all
in the Grandmaster norm section there
are nine thousand dollars on the line
the champion walks away with $2,000 and
we'll talk about the prize break down
near the end of the show we know who the
champion is our I am norm section $6,000
on the line with $1,200 going to our
winner okay let's go around the horn and
see what we have here I think we should
probably keep an eye on the key matchups
Alex yeah I definitely agree so let's go
back to Jack's game and see if anything
has changed here so nitrogen 5 rookies 7
Queen f6 has been played maybe that was
actually unnecessary maybe it was better
to take with the knight soon some
options consider also Knight of 6 but
queen of 6 was played Queen c7 and now
he took but now okay the not the not
Queen enough six looks pretty but maybe
doesn't do anything particular so who
knows and position is still kind of
murky so of course anything can happen
but for black to win this position a lot
of very good things have to go his way
here for him to win the game Alex I
understand that Gauri Shankar is
outside he is ready to come in for an
interview after his victory over Aaron
Burr Minsky so I will be back in just a
bit
someone's good so let's all of you who
haven't seen this game that's actually
this game action that was very very
interesting now Yuri went for a very
interesting line c-44 before this line
has recently gotten much more popularity
the idea being III is met with some
moves like Knight c6 or even c5 so
before it's kind of to discourage knight
c6 or c5 and then to play this should be
to e3 and challenge the 194 so mister g4
is also kind of considered one of the
main lines Queen b3 this has been seen
in practice before and it looks like
either black confused the line or didn't
know it that deeply but it looks like f6
in this position is already sort of a
mistake I know that EV o f6 here is much
more common and after e3 to play five
and this is a different story white
sometimes ghost Queen a4 check you know
Bishop d7 and it's gets kind of messy
but to play the Bishop g4 and then f6
kind of seems like black confused the
lines a little bit and here ready it
looks like White has a very strong
control over the center and from this
point on White had a good position and
as we'll see later won a nice game so
without further ado we have the
restaurant car with us now you are
thanks for coming congratulations on a
very nice win thank you
so how do you feel about this win what
do you think were the main critical
moments in this game first of all I'm
very happy to win this game because I
needed a win to not lose any rating in
this tournament getting some rating to
because I need to get to 2,400 and every
rating point it's like super valuable
the critical moments I think the opening
after he played f6 I you know this was
already a red line I didn't expect him
to play this line so I had no
recollection I can remember anything so
I started taking some time and I think
yeah f6 seems a little bit weird yeah
seems like it doesn't go together well
with Bishop g4 yes Queen b3 is already
useful in this position yes and Bishop
g4 is like yeah I mean it's a pretty
rare position already so none of us knew
the theory here pretty much but I
thought III was the best I was also
considering h3 but probably e3 seems to
be like it
first maybe also is a subtle nuances
worth considering and of course it
requires deep enough I figure out which
one is rather but III is definitely very
logical he surprised me with taking
actually so you expected e5 right I
think so yeah
it's hard to say you know and what would
you do probably here probably just take
probably yeah maybe he doesn't have to
take maybe he can play knight c6 or
something or just takes of three first I
don't know it reason be said yeah it's
it's crazy still a very messy position I
mean it definitely requires a lot of
analysis there's also something to be
said about just keeping the attention
and going this should be too right which
might also be a possible yeah am I was
considering that or even Bishop eat so
defending and then kind of put later
yeah it's it's a position that requires
very deep analysis even the move you
later plate c5 also makes sense yes it
does seem like at least if five was
practically better because at least you
know it gives you a choice you have to
now think about what you're gonna do
yes and whenever you give a personal
choice it means they spend time and you
know it's what you know de was probably
I wasn't sure how to take back here Fe
they both look really good F he looked
more ambitious more imbalanced so I just
played that instead des fine too I guess
but yeah D is also a relatively a nice
advantage for you but Fe was certainly
probably not inviting me and now maybe
block should at some point think about
playing a five right like maybe even
here if I I think I'll just play b5
right and then yeah b5 maybe now 97 or
85 be four hours something like that
Bishop III true yeah no I mean that's
it's already kind of a difficult
position yeah that's true so what
happened he five nights III yeah I don't
know what else to play besides Knight c3
I mean everyone wants to draw back so
it's like yeah seem natural to me yeah
just a very complex game yeah I'd c6 a3
yeah I wasn't sure about knight c6
either he was playing pretty fast and I
was taking a lot of time to get some
advantage in the opening that was the
strategy
maybe you should really try to play a 5
at some point and just to say about that
it's very common it's not not clear at
all what's gone but then at least Knight
goes to d7 and maybe gaining another
temple and c4 could be met with some f5
very complex crazy actually better
somehow should be somehow better but of
course it's like one of these positions
were one mistaken yeah you know I'm
going away right what I was worried
about during this game was like I take
my time get a good position but it's not
enough and the timely that he has would
you know would neutralize everything so
right I don't gain a significant
advantage in in the opening I'm gonna be
in trouble but the game is for you as
you're used to playing okay so at least
you know the positive thing for you is
you know how to play when you're a time
pressure not used to it yeah not a good
thing yeah yeah a3 Queen d7 c5 yeah I
wasn't sure about c5 I the main reason
for see if I was to not let him Castle
queenside even though castling queenside
is pretty dangerous as it is I think the
better way to play was maybe Bishop e2
in this castle but you know just to do
up your pieces and we should be to roopd
1.d4 something like that probably
possibly yeah
c5 Bishop please go strong definitely
strong move you know now I can't play
Bishop b4 and emergency for anymore why
not I mean I can but you know I thought
I should keep my LightSquared Bishop but
maybe I could have tried it I was the
only thing on cleaning a core there it's
also interesting right I mean anything
is playable and such a true yeah I want
to keep the tension more you know win it
for this very reasonable though Knight
h6 this should be 2 and g5 yeah this was
again very fast and I know that I had
something here for sure but it was like
should I play fast and not take
advantage of these moves or should I
take my time and try to always a tricky
balance yeah and I play 94 pretty
quickly and I kind of started regretting
it once I realized that there was
nothing I mean it was a move that was
played basically mostly on intuition
just feel I thought that you know
usually I knew PI G 494 seems like a
nice run all these tactics of
sacrificing your Knights somehow or
maybe B 5 C 6 you know if it goes and
then 95 and some lines uh-huh so it
wasn't really sure again what the right
way to proceed wasn't this position
maybe just castle
yeah Castle is possible too I just I
just got excited I played 94 pretty
quickly this I thought maybe to see
where his Bishop goes he gonna play
Bishop e7 or Bishop g7 because Bishop do
you sound looks really suspicious
because of this B 5 C 6 nights
idea you know that was that's the one I
was going for in the 85 97 98 and c5
yeah there were some interesting ideas
yeah it's very complicated for sure yeah
the problem is ninety fourths not a
developing move looks like and the
Bishop e7 or Bishop g7 is so yeah seems
like it helps him more than you maybe
yes maybe why not you force it looks
aggressive but it's actually not that
great Eames a little but you know like
emotional but yes possibly happens you
know but still you know your position is
very good yeah I castles here at this
point I wonder play C six instead of
castling actually and I probably could
have played it but again it's very
difficult he takes Knight c5 Queen c7
takes on CC six and then Queen takes
Knight takes c6 also they might say yeah
and then pawn if I take with the pawn
and then Queen d6 I was like I don't
really understand what I achieved from
all of this slower I don't know even
just she forever right oh yeah yeah so
again I didn't feel like I'm developed
enough and I got the bishop pair but
it's not enough like no castles is
logical because yeah you're not
developed enough right go for
complications yet unless they win by
force right right that's h3 that was
actually a good prophylactically move
otherwise she was gonna go at g4 maybe I
took a lot of time for AC because I
wasn't sure I want to play d4 or
something but it's not possible at all
right so HD was the only thing I could
do 44 it's too crazy and yeah so I
wasn't sure what's going on here so HD
was I was pretty sad to play it's such a
slow moving this position but blacks
pieces are also pretty but it's very
interesting that makes a lot of sense
right right if you go back a little bit
I was I was thinking of this been
Feingold trick in a video I saw on
YouTube before he castled
I wanted to go something like you know
c6 Queen moves away and then we're a
seven or something I mean not right now
obviously but if the Queen was on e7 you
can go like d6 check and queen takes a
seven I mean it was thinking in some
lines were this is a there's an idea but
of course it doesn't work but I was like
is there a way to make this work you
know Queen takes a seven and then he
takes and I can take with the pawns oh
right I've been found go videoed I know
I forgot it again so but it doesn't work
obviously yes good good
shout outs of been fine yeah as always
yeah so here maybe she should try to put
the knight enough seven song
and then five maybe more harmonious yeah
I would be could be four right probably
something like that yeah maybe there's
Queenie seven first so this should be
two and then maybe try some see six yeah
it's so it's difficult for him but yeah
something more solid would have been
better
definitely then he played Knight f5
which look pretty dangerous but when I
saw night if I knew that I could play
some g4d for in the future right um you
know it's cuz I'm so mo had in
development so nobody so I should play
aggressively right yeah this one was a
really gift p6 for sure but here I
started getting low on time so I knew
that if I better finish this game I
can't let it drag on forever so that
kind of helped me make some risky
decisions are not really risky but some
aggressive decisions all right nothing
pretty good because you're just
restricting his nice right for the Sun I
think every move from now and it's like
a forcing move there's something to be
said about d4 right away by the way but
even c6 looks kind of DS yeah I mean I
just want to see where his Queen goes I
mean you can go Queen defy Queen b3 that
was probably better but then you know I
mean I'm low on time and he wants to
trade Queens I'll play for an insurer
yeah but the Queen's off the board it's
fine yeah any Queen see it pretty fast
yeah I think I'm close to winning now in
terms of like the attack so here I saw
an interesting idea of any player should
be Viking like trade Knights go rook a
fire rookie fire and then you know so so
this would happen in the game exactly
what a few player really in the
classical away and go Bishop c4 trade
off his only active piece and just yeah
I could've done so basically I wanted to
just go for the attack right away
probably this was better
I saw one line and I didn't bother to
consider the other lines basically kind
of more like right though really
political right it is clinical for sure
it's good when you're low on time and
you find one good line you're like okay
this is good enough right and I don't
need to find a better one right so
that's that's what I was going for sure
no 93 is also a very big advance yeah so
here I saw that I had to take with the
rook and I was really excited to play
this because I know that he's gonna 90%
sure he's gonna play nice d5 Knight b3
haha
so cuz I'm low on time yeah so when I
saw that I can go rubies Luke G fine
Ruby said I thought this has to be good
because even if I lose the rook on a1
his route gonna eight is dead right yeah
so that's like a wash it's fine so then
I should be able to win with my I just
count the material I have too many
attackers yes Luke F son wasn't so yes
because you have basically four
attackers on the king
the kingís has almost no defender all
the pieces are in the queenside so that
was a very very good judge right if he
takes on anyone right now for the
viewers maybe just I'll just take on f6
King g8 Queen g5 king f7 Queen d7 and
Queen e7 is mate mm-hmm that's just one
of the mates so so he tried some really
nice six at Queen e8 I think you can
play it but that's also just I think
I'll just play Bishop f6 even light say
yeah that's good I think I calculate
Bishop f6 King g8 and Bishop d3 right
sweetly fibers there's no no defense
from yeah so that's also crushing so oh
look f7 yeah we have six Queen g5 yeah
Bishop g7 if he goes yeah sorry any play
Bishop g7 because King e8 and I wasn't
sure Keaney ate the night of six
bringing the last piece in the game and
it seems it's really aesthetically
pleasing to bring it at the last piece
pretty much yeah black ruler has nothing
to do it yeah surprising he has no moves
here my threat is I mean maybe you can
play some move like night to c5 here to
show what am I made in like made in a
few moves right yes 57 kingi 897 and
then that's a nice yeah that's just one
of the numerous thread there's no he has
literally no no moves here no yeah
that's there's one interesting way she
could have an earlier actually
so Bishop e6 looks like the natural move
when he played attack my rook but Bishop
f7 looks bad but it was a better tribe
yeah because I for route takes g5 he has
Bishop g6 and here I wasn't sure what do
care but I have a backup here I can just
take on c5 and just play a better
position but there's also probably other
ways to play I was happy with just like
this position but probably there's other
ways to play yeah maybe Knight h5 night
of five yeah it's crazy 96 and all that
stuff right yeah but of course why does
you know you're guaranteed to be much
better than the matter one right pretty
much takes d5 so yeah I was a long time
so I was happy to just go for the attack
and if I go down in flames that's fine
and I probably couldn't because it's
rooks on a8 and Queen yeah yeah this one
on c6 is worth like a piece in this
position for sure yeah because it
restricts the Queen and the rook yeah
it's yeah yeah this is temporarily yeah
so no that was a very very nice game by
you you know very cool good good way to
finish the tournament yes so now you
know you get
the tournament on a very good no note
right right happy you didn't gum better
here yeah five-and-a-half definitely
very solid good score of course I'm sure
you're hoping for even better but
another the less you know still nice
step in the right direction and I wish
you all the best in your quest and
becoming and I am okay thank you so much
thanks a lot for coming [ __ ] yeah so
that was guy you're Shankar who just won
a very nice game and basically I got you
were as we saw finished on a very nice
salt +2 but unfortunately for Aaron very
very difficult tournament for him two
out of nine you know I'm sure he wants
to forget this tournament as soon as
possible but hopefully he will learn a
lot from this tournament and make right
conclusions for himself and come back
strong you know we all have sometimes
math tournaments and what matters is how
we recover from them and how much we
learn from the tournaments so with that
said let's go back and see if there are
any new updates in the air at games so
it looks like more or less the same
thing basically black kept pushing the
pawns the white is basically centralize
the King & King g3 and basically looks
like with perfect plate this should be a
draw and so pretty much nothing major
has changed so far and let's also take a
look at whether there are any big
updates and the jockey and from what I
could see in this game things have
gotten a little bit better for black
actually so as I mentioned before I
didn't really like the move Queen f6
that much and now after a four you know
Knights now being attacked and notice
how if let's say white would have played
this first after a four you can go
Knight of six tempering the bishop but
now the Queen is kind of in the way so
now you cannot do that you cannot go
Knight of 6 obviously taken and if 95
Bishop a5 and everything is in control
so that gave black a chance tone double
is pause and create some counter play so
Queen nightshade King b7 Knight of six
was played but now the Queen is kind of
out of play and White's pieces kind of
are a little bit uncoordinated Bishop f3
was played rook e1 average
ge5 very logical move just trying to
secure the bishop on a three and maybe
activating the rook rook e3 Bishop c6
Queen G queen of eight before g4 and g4
might very well have been a mistake
because after G 44 that opens up some
new targets essentially for black I mean
at least the move maybe it's not a
mistake but it's a very double-edged
move so a3 might have been safer but g4
was play d5 g5 so I mean the idea makes
sense trying to secure the night but now
at least black can play a move like
rookie 5 which was played in the game
and white played Queen h6 and I think
white is still kind of holding in there
but White's pieces are a little bit
offside the knight of six looks
absolutely pretty protected by the point
but what exactly does it do besides
putting a little bit of pressure on e4
it's not so clear and in the meantime
black might try it use like c4 and then
b5 and maybe get some Queen side
initiative so at least it looks like a
position where the tide is shifting a
little bit in blacks favor and a couple
of more inaccuracies by white can
suddenly give Jack very real winning
chances in this game so not all hope is
lost for a playoff still I'm a little
surprised based on the situation we came
on the air can we jump over to our other
division with Rosen versus Kiera the we
have some pawns I mean is this game just
gonna be drawn out right I mean got
passed pawns here Oh draw it out right I
mean I don't know I mean it's still act
as I said it's still unclear I think
draw is by far the most likely result in
this position but of course it's still
possible for one side to go wrong here
right but I just don't really seek
Keaton with twenty minutes on the clock
and also just needing a draw to over
press here and really mess up to this
the point of losing this game I mean
certainly it's very hard to win and
probably not winnable but to lose it's
you know you have to really I think miss
play this and even know if if Rosen win
somehow then we're looking at a
three-way playoff if he does not win if
any other score happens then carriage
just wins the event in regulation let's
shall we take a look at some games that
are not art yeah I think the game with
between Jacobson and she karate is kind
of winding down and it might really very
well be about to finish because Aaron
Jacobsen is his king looks absolutely
unhappy it's the King without any
clothes you know has no points
protecting I mean just in a very bad
shape
materially you know actually black is
worse than one two three four one two so
black is technically down to pieces for
like three bones but objectively
speaking black is completely winning
because blacks just has a winning attack
and in fact black has a you know black
in the game played Bishop a7 which
actually amazing enough it blew the
whole advantage amazingly enough black
here had a very very nice continuation
which would have absolutely won the game
so challenge you viewers to see if you
can find it if you want more time pause
the video so here it was Ruby Tzu double
exclamation mark would have won the game
outright the attack is unstoppable its
removal of the guard tactic after Bishop
takes b2
we now go Bishop g3 king e to and now we
go 94 and we we know we almost pick up
the Queen but we actually could deliver
mate Queen afore and after King III we
also go queen of four so whereas the
difference being if you go Bishop g4
first there is kim jiwan's so you might
ask well what happens here after king g1
well here after king g1 we go Bishop h4
check sorry
Bishop f4 check King each one is met by
night g3 check King G 194 King here
Queen h3 King JaJuan and now the key
point why we got rid of this Bishop here
Bishop
three rook have to fish snakes of two so
this was actually for a computer this is
very easy of course but for not for a
human but for the human player this is
very hard to to find this very subtle
nuance and this would have this would
have won the game I mean actually it
might even be best to go ninety-four
it's it is still very messy but long
story short this this was winning or
also you can go Bishop g2 g3 first king
here in this rough for first and then if
king of to here there and now you have
Ruby to takes and now you have 94 take
some Queen III so actually it was harder
than it looks
the win but instead in the game and
there were some interesting other
interesting developments so in the game
we had King e1 bishop a7 King you one
wrong check Queen g3 King the two now
the king is can escape but in fact the
best move to defend was actually King e2
and in this position I'm not actually
sure if white black has anything better
than a perpetual and it still looks very
complex only maybe black does but it's a
very complex Alex let's shift over to
our Grandmaster dorm key matchup because
it looks like Jim Boley ik now has a big
lead over Andrew Hong and this this
could put him in first if he wins right
here and that is indeed a breaking news
because white has just made some very
big mistakes okay this is where we left
off this was fine
Queen e6 and now white played Queen of
four and this move is a huge huge
blunder white have to just play move
like be three or maybe King be one just
defending everything or maybe even Queen
g3 indirectly defending but you put
queen of four and that suddenly allowed
black to play rook f5 and now the queen
is attacked and white just cannot hold
on to all his pawns if white goes here
now you can even take rook takes of six
and win the piece so white tried Queen
g3 but now you just lose the pawn innate
to and you
get attacked so humongous blunder by
Andrew honk and now black in this
position after Queen f1 was displayed is
totally winning and it's very much in
cruise control and at this point I would
be very shocked if White's somehow
survived this so a very huge development
here so you guys might be infer very
nice treat we might actually see a
playoff today and I would start at 4:00
p.m. Central time if we do just uh it
won't be too long of a break after the
regular round is over and this is what
exactly and this is exactly what
happened rook takes up two kings you won
and now black and play root Jitsu or
Queen jutsu and it's gonna be an end
game that's completely winning now maybe
it was not even the best way to play
like this maybe c4 was even more
clinical with the idea of threatening c3
with mates and after this Bishop a4 who
keeps up Queen a one King the to rock f3
might even we have have been like even
more winning but even what you know
Jacques went for should also be totally
winning for black but of course both
players are in time pressure white more
than black but still time can definitely
be a factor let's go back to where we
were with Jacobson versus Aaron Jacobsen
versus Chi karate yes so here we had a
few more moves played so had night so we
had King the two played which actually
looks like a mistake because now black
could play 93 notice how the bishop does
not control the three square anymore
rookie won Queen Jitsu and now black is
actually just just winning there seems
to be no defense against unstoppable
attack go in G to Rou keep super index
of one black picked up the rook but the
worst em think for white is that attack
still continuous and White's scrambling
somehow for defense with 91 materially
he still might be somehow okay but of
course the king and the - boy does it
not feel comfortable here on D - so with
that said that game can finish any
moment let's
if any new updates and a fact we have
breaking news this game has just
officially ended in a draw Keaton has
offered the draw after playing g3 and
Eric realized that the only way he can
possibly miraculous the witness may be
white over presses but you know the
chances for that is almost none and you
know you know they're both players are
you know well aware that the chances of
white winning this is almost in
existence so white took the draught so
at least make sure to secure you know
tie for third because in also gallery 1
which means that got yours at five and a
half and definitely Eric did not want to
go behind got you worried for example in
the standings because there's also my
other prizes to be played for so at this
point draw was very practical decision
no point of really going for broke in
this position and that leaves us with
Keaton kiev row beating the deserve it
winner of the tournaments and indeed the
number three seed from the I am norm
group international master from San
Diego representing the USA 31 year old
Keaton Kyra is the champion of our Group
B but this thing is still going on back
to group a back to rube and so far no
updates here in the Jack game Jack is
still thinking how to you know convert
this winning position so let's take a
look at a game we haven't looked at yet
today Brendan Jacobsen against Justin
Wang and in this position boy do these
pawns look very strong right I mean sure
these black also has passers but I mean
these pastors are very slow compared to
whites whites passers are you know
having like running shoes on I mean
they're about so Queen at any moment and
yeah and this position white is
definitely very much in control and the
interesting thing about this game is
that Brandon he's been having you know a
difficult tournament and at at some
point he just decided let's just have
fun and play some chess and sometimes
it's good to kind of get your mind off
of prep and out of openings and just try
to play a fun game without too much you
know worrying about the results so he
played the one before which is actually
you know not such a bad move I think and
it's one of these lines which was very
sharp white gave up a central porn I
mean white took essential corn black
took a wing porn but black is a little
bit ahead in development and in this
kind of complex game actually Brandon
seems played just a little bit because
wide in the long run has the center and
it seems like black didn't take
advantage of his initiative in the best
way and you know position is still
roughly equal but it seems like at some
point this kind of got very good for
white because again central points this
game is a good indication of why Center
is still better than then central pawns
are still usually better than the wing
points central Torn's impact the game
more and so far
Brandon's technique has also been very
good and we know we've had couple of
more moves played this should be for
king e5 and king g5 another nice move
centralizing the King and g5 is probably
next and probably we should expect that
white would win this game and in the
meantime in the end Rohan game Queens
have been traded off so after King g1
queen g2 was played maybe Ruby g2 was a
little better but after this night 64
was played and black played King c7 so
actually black is only a pawn up but the
thing is white is very much tied down
because of white ever moves this night
the pawn will fall and black is at some
point threatening to little by little
activate the King and I would say black
is still winning I mean he did not want
to go Ruby for right away of course
because of ninety-six check so that's
why the move King c7 it's just the
prophylactic move and now next move he
wants to go route c4 pick up the g5 pawn
and little by little try to win two
pawns up but of course winning two pawns
up is not as trivial task as it seems as
I've learned from my youth championship
game against a wonder Liang so this
could still be you know a fight for
black to win but you know black is of
course winning in this position but this
will you know not happen you know
overnight you know this you know will
take some work
to do for black to win this game all
right as we were still looking for heat
and Kira we would like to interview him
of course being the champion of our B
group but while we're waiting on that we
still have a few games in progress yeah
and this game you know it's now becoming
a very easy technical task
you know black here played Quinnie for
setting up some discoveries a white
plane I have 395 and now black is just
winning a bunch of material black
actually decided to simplify into
winning endgame here and yeah so now
after all smoke has cleared black will
just basically be up quite a lot of
material either up like these three
pawns or maybe even more than that so
this is not gonna last too long
I would think technically black is only
up two pawns but you know now after rook
takes T three black is up a piece white
ride 95 but after rook e3 it looks like
black could just even remain up a piece
so this game will be over at any moment
as well and this game would pretty much
off but there's one game we haven't
looked at yet at all and that game is
between Rochelle Wu who had a nice win
yesterday against Aaron Burr Vince key
and Peter Gennaro's all right I've got
some news here Alex we're gonna have
international master Eric Rosen tied for
second place final score in the I am
norm section and then we'll have our
champion of that division come in for an
interview sounds good so before we get
there let's take a look we already took
a look at that game more closely so will
I'll definitely players more in deep
depth but let's quickly take a look and
see what happened in this game this is
Peter against Rochelle rather Rachelle's
playing white it looks like started with
the relatively slow Queens gambit
declined but looks like black got a very
comfortable game right away because
looks like this efore move was premature
allowed this c5 push and here white
maybe should take on a six but hit
sookie 5q play d5 and now black looks
like he's just winning opponent from
this point on probably black had better
ways to convert this but as it was
Rochelle defended very resilient Lee
just like showing her very good defense
of
skills yesterday against Aaron Grubb in
ski and even managing the turning the
tables later on here also Rochelle is
certainly proven to be a very tough
defender actually was able to win back
the poor and well actually here maybe
block was again winning but in any event
now we're looking at a position which
objectively should probably be closer to
a draw than white then black winning and
with that said we have Eric Rosen with
us here to talk about the game he just
played against Keaton and tournaments so
Eric thanks a lot for coming
yeah good to be back yeah thanks is
showing very good sports because
sometimes it's unpleasant to come you
know when you know we don't get the
result of what but thanks a lot for
coming anyway
I mean draw was fair result yeah and I
was very lucky not to lose given the
position of going in today that's true
at some point it was looking very
dangerous for you so yeah what do you
think were the main critical moments do
you think you were ever at some point
first of all better out of the opening I
mean I really liked my position if we go
forward through most of the opening the
first critical moment was when I played
they take C 6 and 9 a for right 96 194
very common idea in the structure to
like go for C for B 3 and play very
positionally mm-hmm
and then he he responded pretty
naturally they grew up e8 c4 c5 and then
I thought the position would just play
itself like I don't know I want to put
like the Queen on C to work on d1 but I
think in this position maybe I should
have played f4 first because what he did
in the game he brought the night from
i-5 to c6 and then the d4 square was
kind of yeah this here he if he wants to
bring mighty would have to go from b8
but then he has to lose another tempo to
the rook and yes so maybe f4 was more
precise but in any event it looks like
the kind of slow game which is good to
get in them must-win game you know just
trying to kind of keep theses on the
board and so on exactly so I was I was
feeling comfortable there's a couple
different ideas
or while in position like this one is to
focus in the center and double on the D
file and the other idea is to just throw
pawns at the Kings side so that's what I
just ended up doing is throwing all my
pawns in hindsight maybe it was of
course risky probably not the like best
like objective option but it was
interesting like starting with g5 the
ship g7 h4 and I mean I'm fantasizing
about like each 5f5 and it came true in
the game but it didn't turn out so well
for me mm-hmm if we go forward just a
few more moves 22 I mean things are
still pretty controlled play h5 84 and
then I think f5 is just a big mistake
yeah so what what exactly did you
underestimate when you played a 5 so I
mean I was envisioning either getting a
pawn to f6 or removing his econ and
getting a Knight to d5 but concretely I
think I just missed after f5 he takes
that 5 he takes that 5 he has Queen e7
also you owe your original plan was eat
six of five right
and then say you're 27 it gets a little
bit if he caused these minor pieces on
the still unclear by the way I've takes
g6 Queen takes c3 maybe yeah I was
trying to like understand this variation
yeah rook takes f7 it still could be
anyone's game right my not only two is
still yeah Bishop d5 or maybe can you
take on b7 yeah maybe you could yeah I
could have still gone for this mm-hmm
I think I freaked out a little bit
because my miss Queenie Saturn you know
what sometimes happens and this is
something I want to talk about sure it
happens you know with me it happens to
be like low my low rate students will
happen to all of us right when we
calculate a certain line and we don't
let say a lot like a certain option
sometimes we just immediately assume we
should play the other option because
let's say we don't like option a so we
just say okay let's just go up after
option B but an option B might end up
becoming much worse you know so it's
like one of these things where it's it's
a common kind of chess mistake which we
all have to try to really control
ourselves and sometimes even when we
don't likes one option particularly we
should still not at automatically assume
that you know we have to play the other
one you know what I mean that's truly I
you should never reject lines like too
early I was a difficult situation for me
too because yeah I felt like I'm in a
must-win situation right yeah and I
probably just over pushed
yeah because neither for I guess the
problem with that move is that you never
really get with you five score because
the bishop just strains it off exactly
well right rather after 94 and was quite
strong yeah now I felt like my position
is just crumbling here did you missed up
my move 94 yes yeah I was just missing
another typical kind of mistake
sometimes we make is that we kind of
assume we control that square but we
forgot that you know but at once we move
the knight then suddenly we lose control
over that square another typical
visualization mistake in this position
yeah what else could have you done maybe
for some reason the engine is suggesting
this it looks strange to me but maybe
just going here in the Knight c3 and
then trying to go for some 95 maybe
going back to this plan and we may be
next III immediately yeah I was trying
to understand whether attention yeah
that's what I was thinking about that
yeah I was trying to understand why
would you want to go h6 but what if you
let's like we'll go Queen b6 I mean this
is very subtle I mean you know why to
play h6 I mean to me it's actually not
clear like let's say a B a B but maybe
you can go let's say Knight d5 and if
Queen b6 you can somehow take and but I
don't mean you know if we go back to the
position with without let's say h h6 I'm
wondering if that could be playable
Knight 66 but now is there crook text e6
quint x d6 and beats like say five and
could it be that including h6 and vivid
shade make a difference but anyway this
very yet I mean usually the rule is you
should leave the tension because black
almost never wants to take on but that
is true that's why h6 is actually a very
counterintuitive move but maybe it's
just some very very deep concept that
we're both not seeing but the alpha 0
type
yeah but anyway a5 was was played h6
definitely not a very human move and
okay after 94 I thought I was I mean I'm
just getting like yeah looks looks
pretty lost but you know you managed to
you know find very good practical
chances that actually salvage draw out
of this
yeah maybe Queen b7 wasn't the best move
either right or yeah I mean there's a
lot of ideas for black and I mean he's
in a situation yes his to decide like
what path to go down
yeah possibly there was better ways to
play but in any event the way he played
was of course very practical especially
given draw is okay for him yeah
especially because they the other game
and maybe around this point yes so it
makes sense to go for something without
any risks but amazingly enough it's it
actually seemed like he really miss
played this position for example right
around here he's still doing very well
but here he missed another very nice
opportunity I don't know if you so I was
wondering rookie a Kim D - Bishop e3
Bishop e3 I think King C 2 is kind of
still oh okay for you so I wasn't sure
how to evaluate this rook ending like
row 61 King 61 takes up 4 and then he
starts pushing it still looks very
dangerous but this may be some some
practical chances but a better line for
black actually might be to play rook e3
instead and amazingly enough this looks
like it's just completely finished
because if you take here Bishop takes c3
sheykh is winning and if you take here
this is also completely winning so the
only move was actually rook h3 to just
continue the game but then after takes
takes through g3 it's clear that black
is totally accepted upon yeah yeah even
even in some fantasy line like where you
actually give up this I would say even
this is probably should be somehow close
to winning would be my guess because
although this I'm not as sure but in
this position you can even you know here
you can even keep the bishop and then
take on c5 and never you know risk
losing and certainly very very delicious
ravage is winning it's beautiful move
rookie yeah sure some students so maybe
you saw a key 8th but maybe didn't see
you
look III so I was also getting low on
time and I think he was trying to just
keep the pressure and yeah but I mean I
think it's generally not a very good
idea if you're in a better position I
mean it's better not to play on
opponents time and yeah I think it looks
like he yeah are you ready here for
black very tricky yeah here it's already
very hard to win maybe it's already
actually closer to a draw and in the
final position any thoughts about
playing out the position and then I was
thinking about it but he had like over
20 minutes and I had less than two
minutes
and of course okay if I wait and I
forced the tie rake but I mean I was
looking at some lines where it seems
like black can easily draw for example
okay of course I want to play tonight
takes off six here hoping to check me in
on each five but then to either g2 or
even like Bishop takes f6 and Rose I
think well that's so yeah well that
that's probably a draw but g2 probably
wins for a block oh really oh so he was
winning in final position no no he's not
I know it because I if I'm playing
around I was gonna play that takes us oh
I see well then you definitely made the
right decision of taking a draw because
nitrix of six would have been a huge
blunder because after she gets from King
she 394 king f 3 g5 here yeah route C 5
bush before and I think the thing about
this position is that there's just no
progress you can ever make and black
will just come with the rook oh really
okay it okay three it's just you're kind
of stuck you don't have any on can you
lay any more
I can't move my people on at some point
like 57 rooks you seven yeah you're just
not in time not nearly in time I'm going
okay three or a once back always has d5
is necessary even d5 but I mean I think
even without d5 so so breaking news to
everybody
Jackson Bullock did just win officially
so now we're gonna have a playoff
between Jack and Dennis so so yours
don't go anywhere
you know we're gonna be back in life
like at four o'clock st. Louis
but you know in the meantime yeah
so the best move instead of night 6f6
was night III actually keeping the
tension and then trying to go rogue f1
and then you're still drawing but of
course yeah if you're going night six of
six then you made absolutely right
decision of taking the draw and it's so
hard to play accurately in this
situation there's pressure yeah so um
still a very solid result for you
nevertheless I know you were hoping for
more going in so today but in any event
still very saw the results shared third
any last-minute thoughts on this
tournament sure third Sheren
oh because Louise stories is well those
stories drew yes right he got six and
then Keaton has six and half and you're
sharing with the you who won today I see
yeah I think overall it was pretty solid
I was happy to be in the situation I was
in last rounds has some interesting
flights had one tough loss but a lot of
interesting games yeah well Erica is
always with a positive mindset
thanks for coming here thanks once again
for being good sport and showing your
thought process during the game and wish
you best of luck in your future
encounters and in your quest for
hopefully at some point fighting for the
GM title from day yeah alright no
problem okay so with that said let's
quickly update you on what happened
exactly in the judge Tim bullier game
wow it looks like white completely ran
out of pieces so what exactly happened
in the last few moments so we were left
off some around here where a block was
nursing an extra phone with a better
game but but now it looks like black
found a very nice maneuver of
repositioning the Bishop to h5 here note
rookie to maybe was even quicker but
this was also very smooth and now he
finally did find rookie to endure and
now black white was maybe hoping for
last minute stale matrix hoping very
desperately hoping for this and some
Perpetual crazy rope you know of course
if you take it
they'll mid but of course you know none
of that happened
King eight Bishop takes g7 Russia Aiden
a white had no pieces left and white had
nothing better to do than to resign and
here we have the man of the hour the one
and only kidding here congratulations to
Keaton thanks Alex
so how do you feel about this
well bittersweet because as you know a
little bit disappointing did not convert
that endgame yeah no I understand but
still you know you got the job done you
know first places first place so yeah
and I mean this was a very tough
tournament a lot very strong capable
players so I'm definitely honored to be
able to win this event yeah
so hopefully up some day you don't
you'll get a chance to play in the GM
non-permanent fighting for the GM that
would be awesome I would love it GM
norms but in the meantime let's take a
look at those games so what do you think
were the main critical moments in this
game well I watched your analysis with
Eric and it was very interesting I agree
with what you guys were saying about
like some of the critical moments in the
opening now first of all Eric could play
the different opening with whitey than
every single game this tournament so I
basically decided there's no way I can
prepare it I tell he's gonna play yeah
now he might have seen my game they lost
a boorish one of these tournaments 93 86
and it was like the same kind of idea
with g3 like you play it's like the most
alright I did that time so that's why I
decided to go for a different setup here
because to get him off the property in
some of those positions I might not need
a six yeah exactly oh yeah
but yeah I think it was a very normal
game I mean he went a little silly
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean I played
Sicilian my whole life so I was you know
feeling comfortable yeah even if you
have to play slightly new you're still
come to me yeah I know enough themes but
yeah it was a very competitive game I
offered him a draw
early in the
game but I think he made the right
decision I mean try to try to win and
mm-hmm
fight for what you can get so I want
moment did you feel like your position
starting to get very good definitely
after f5 and he takes a five
although the variation that you guys
analyzed it was completely nuts and I
know I don't know how many people would
see that maybe no after he takes f5 I
thought black was like borderline
winning mm-hmm yeah it looks that way
too but yeah it looks like it's maybe
not so I thought he just missed Queen e7
probably yeah Queen would have been and
I mean to your credit even if it's nots
it's like it's not likely that you're
gonna be worse than that line yeah I I
have to go for it for sure I mean I
can't just sit around with him play f6
no of course so it looks like yeah
here's where he didn't really choose the
right plan maybe he should try some
Knight c3 plan yeah
but yeah he missed Queen d7 and that was
pretty much all it took for you to
really take over the game yeah show how
you know you've really played the game
pretty well up to the support thanks
yeah I mean I I thought I had a the
right feel for like how the weight in
these positions you know keeping the
tension and putting the piece of some
good squares and then you know when
opportunity strikes strike for a counter
play right exactly
this is exactly how we play Sicilian
especially these slow Sicilians like the
con or the tamanna' for these guys right
so around here it's about conversion but
I want to give Eric credit because he
defended this just extremely well I mean
this is a pretty miserable position for
white would be very easy for him to just
kind of give up psychologically but he
was really focused and resilient and he
just found all the best chances yeah
like come against Rochelle he's just
very resilient player yeah so you really
got to beat them quite a long time
together giving it a lot of credit for
that put him away and and here you
probably decided to go for the practical
choice because at this point you knew
that draw is definitely gonna be good
enough so no reason right go for well
objectively maybe it was better to try
to keep Queens on the board because the
scheme is kind of weaker than yours
yeah being move like rook c8 Bishop of
to rock g4 and oh no he doesn't have
Queen earth
yeah okay maybe if I'd seen that I would
have done it
Ruchi for was of course very practical
as well should also be very good winning
chances yeah well and then I missed this
beautiful idea roki three that you guys
that I show so you probably you know
sort of like what I wasn't looking for
okay yeah it's like if if you gave it to
me as a puzzle I would find it for us
yeah but you didn't realize that I
didn't realize it existed yeah
rookie a rookie three of course very
easy to miss and and I also I think I
overestimated this endgame because I
still thought it should be just
completely winning I mean with bishop
against Knight you two connected
passport well it feels like your bishop
is kind of stupid it's like yeah yes
hearing a lot of the practical problems
because when his Knight goes to d5 c5
isn't good for my bishop because he
always says this before shot or I can't
take because it'll be three and yeah you
know he's coordinating very well the
sudden is befalling becomes dangerous
and his knight is active yeah it's in
fact it might already not be winning
objectively yeah well yeah looks like
not at some point I even thought okay I
have to be a little careful so now that
was a very well timed draw for to me at
least make sure you yeah yeah no the
reason I offer the jaw I did think that
Knight takes f6 was a draw but I didn't
see that beautiful variation you pointed
out where blacks actually winning you
know sometimes the last round of the
tournament and late late in the game my
calculation isn't you know sometimes I'm
seeing some ghosts ya know but in any
event I mean you know draw still secured
you first so there's no reason to go for
a complete risk right exactly I'd live
rating points yeah I mean I did I didn't
care about the rating I mean really
trying to win it was just the principle
of you know I thought my position was
winning and yeah to try to convert of
course knowing earlier earlier part of
course you should never you know give
him a draw but at this point okay yeah I
already felt like I'm probably not
winning so yeah no that was that was a
good practical decision so that was good
congratulations yeah what are your plans
going forward thank you very much well
this wasn't enough chess for me so I'm
going this [ __ ]
go tonight and say in the Chicago Outfit
already it started sterile not tomorrow
thank God but on Thursday yeah so there
you'll have a chance to fight for a GM
door hopefully oh yeah hopefully
hopefully at least I'll get to play some
GM's hopefully you've gained some ground
towards that ultimate 2500 goal and then
once you're there was a long road but
yeah Road but you know you got to start
somewhere and this was a very good
starting place it was closer when I was
above the 70 points higher than that is
true but we've all went from ups and
downs you know at some point I was so 25
20 you know after being 2600 before so
there's always you know room for
comeback and improvement absolutely
you're always very inspirational Alex
appreciate that so thanks a lot for
coming and I wish you best of luck in
your quest to becoming a stronger player
getting your norms and in everything
else in your life thank you very much
Alex likewise thanks for coming alright
so that was Keaton with a very nice
tournament win so now we you know we see
that she Kurata Fischer did win against
Aaron as you could see it's almost made
white has to capture on e3 and then
after-effects III he's just a baroque
simple winning position and fear Guinot
toes did end up drawing his game against
Rachelle who in the end you know as we
predicted the bishop was gonna be very
hard to deal with and this ended up also
being a draw so all of the games in the
iron door section have finished so there
was only one game still going on which
is Brandon Jacobson against Justin Wang
and looks like Brandon kind of spoiled
his position now it looks like it's just
gonna be a draw
probably rook and Bishop against Luke
potentially and of course as we know
this could be potentially winnable if
opponent makes a mistake but of course
we expect it to be a draw but in the
meantime we're we welcome our guest
Jackson and buuck Jack congratulations
on a very clutch big
right now ya think it was a hard game so
I know you have a playoff to prepare for
so I'm not gonna keep you for too long
so just in a couple of words what were a
couple of very big critical moments you
felt in this position yeah I mean
probably see fire for the bad move
there are you right yeah because I
didn't see this idea d5 d5 I figured my
rug was hanging I figured that you yeah
store your viewers as I explained
earlier I figured that d5 was probably
missed by you and suddenly it's just
very awkward but in this position maybe
you had a move Queen g7 did you consider
that yeah but after Queen d7 she has
Queen e2 queenie - yes and i take on of
three green takes apparently queen bee
528 and it's a it's a drawer I mean I'm
not sure that it's a draw he takes on c5
Knight d5 and room the Apophis okay I'm
losing here here this year you're losing
because of Queen b7 yeah so you have to
go King e8 and then takes takes rook to
you one will be the ones and six yeah
it's still a very wild man and if I
wasn't sure about this position yeah
it's very risky yeah but I think when
you played c5 you were planning to go
Queen b8 and everything being okay but
then yes so I guess c5 was a practical
mistake because yeah 94 was actually
really the mistake you had to probably
take and go Queen visa yeah but I mean
it's in the cool endgame but a good news
for you is that if you would have played
that you probably wouldn't have know
sometimes we we're kind of blessed by
making some mistakes because then we
actually get more chances in a way
whereas if you would have seen that you
probably wouldn't have gone for this so
yeah this is probably a difficult
position but amazingly it's maybe not so
terrible but of course yeah you your
opponent should go to d8 probably it's
probably winning but we both didn't see
this flame takes Queen h8 King c7 and
just take and yeah white and so what is
probably winning
why maybe it's not winning but of course
why does the olden what was winning
chances and even draw would be bad but
now after this especially queen of six
it seems like a mistake looks like a
pretty one that wasn't
sing-along here I thought like if he
takes only four dozen goes green each a
check takes on h7 mm-hmm then Queen e5
yes and here I get like is that
afternoon k1 I have Queen G 505 but
apparently he might play h4 before he
won and still probably he's winning
apartment after oh c'mon maybe although
there's still some counters yeah three
it's still a kind of unclear but maybe
there's yeah
well anyway it gets quite messy but yeah
this part of the game he kind of
misplayed if he wanted to take on h7 he
should have at least taken right away to
reserve this square for his night but
yeah he he miss plated and suddenly this
is where you probably were getting
optimistic right you know yeah maybe
there's even some chance after four I
was already happy with my position
because I was from Bishop strong Bishop
and you know suddenly a game which can
go either way and suddenly you know he
made a huge well this g45 was already
very risky I think but suddenly he just
made a very very big oversized so after
this moment you probably thought yeah
you're just winning right yeah but
having then at some point they missed
one more so it wasn't that clear anymore
yeah here maybe there was some easier
ways to win I think I some c4 at some
point and attack but yeah but the
problem was it like when I played Queen
f1 I said is that if you place rook e1 I
just take with the rook and that you
didn't see King do you want oh yeah when
I played Kingdom on I was like oh not
easy to him again not as easy I mean
rook g2 maybe was all but better but
good thing for you yeah this end game is
still complete the winner because he's
he has a very weak pawn and your bishop
is better than the night and even though
it's not winning right away but step by
step yeah so just in two terms for my
initiative you see yeah that was a very
nice plan activate the least active
piece putting the bishop where targets
this sense and after Lukie to that was
all she wrote he he was playing for a
very small chance for like a little bit
of a stalemate trick but of course
there's nothing so congratulations on a
very clutch win you know
and again you took some risks you know
but again one who doesn't risk doesn't
drink drink champagne so you know those
who risk you know oftentimes get
rewarded and wish you best of luck in
the in your play of upcoming against
Danish water
thank you thanks for coming all right so
that was that was judge Tim Bullock with
a very big play of upcoming and now we
have the only game remain there's
Brandon Jacobson trying to win this rook
and Bishop against rook end game which
as we all know it's objectively it's a
draw but of course from practical
standpoint of view it's very easy to
mess this up
I've even once once I even won this kind
of end game against the 2700 feed a
player in a 30-second increments so it
is possible to mess up but of course
it's objectively speaking with perfect
play from both sides it is it is a it is
a draw but I'm sure Brandon will try for
all his 50 moves to try to win this end
game but so far black is defending
correctly defending with the
second-ranked defense where the king and
the rook are one fall apart and the rook
is no seventh-ranked and with this setup
there's actually no way to break through
unless you kind of make some mistakes so
with that said we now have our guest
Dennis borsch coming and ok and Dennis
is here so let's bring up his game and
where is it
yeah this is his game so Dennis probably
you were hoping to win outright with
with this draw but I don't mind
like if somebody still wants to play me
sure go ahead
yeah that's that's always a very good
mindset so yeah any quick thoughts on
first of all today's game
yeah I mean it's never easy playing
against two people when one of them is
playing you
the other one is staring at you so
that's kind of a not an easy
psychological situation so even the fact
that this game seems short it was
actually very tense it was very tense
yeah there were quite a few critical
moments so I don't want to keep you too
long obviously but if there are any
critical moments you want to show me
yeah definitely he's pawn sacrifice was
very interesting and that actually shows
the intention of trying to put me under
sighs interesting move by the way I
think I've seen it try by Wesley so in
the Olympiad and I think d5 is probably
the critical test yeah does maybe also
Knight be 392 but this is probably still
preparation right yeah this is line
Queen b6 is very sharp no but to be
honest I checked afterwards and the game
seemed to be fairly very good so all the
moves are new your computer like mmm
takes castles and here I think rook e8
is better and Knight c3 and I think
there's still compensation because
Bishop Bishop h3 means c4 takes takes
and this I feel that like has play but I
think I'm fine yeah no you're definitely
fine you can't be worse you're white
you've played all logical moves yeah so
Knight c3 takes takes this should be
three and yeah well it was rainy ever
was there ever any moment where you felt
like you might be under pressure a bit
more no I think he missed Bishop takes
d4 here which is a nice little
in-between move yeah what if you plays
Bishop takes up three Queen decks of
three 94-94 can I have uh key one night
t2 Queenie something I'd say some of
five yeah yeah this didn't occur to me I
didn't feel that this should be dead bad
yeah yeah procession but to be
yes probably gave more or less
liquidates to a drawing oh yeah that was
the logical wait at the game and then I
mean I could even try a little bit it
takes and see for mm-hmm but it's still
around even and there was no reason that
that boy to do that because Jack's game
at that point can also go either way and
you know we saw what happened in that
game certainly that game could have gone
either way so in any event I wish you
best of luck in your play of upcoming
I'm not gonna ask you for your
strategies I'm just wish you have my
strategies to win your strategy that
sounds like a very good strategy to me
so that was Dennis Bors thanks for
coming thanks for joining us we're
looking forward to seeing a very great
playoff hopefully we swing so great
fighters and let's see if there's been
any updates and the Jacobson game looks
like nothing special has happened still
kind of both players shuffling around
and so far it looks like Black has
everything in control and as we know
that when we have 50 moves without any
piece capturing or any porn moved it
becomes a draw so we started the 50 move
rule that move 70 and this is where and
right now we're at move 82 so this game
consider radical so go all the way to
move 120 before black can theoretically
claim a draw so this game can still go
in a live for a very very long time and
now we have another guest joining us
very soon Kenta Chi karate who won his
game against Aaron Jacobsen which was a
game we didn't really look at to close
until the very very end so Kenta
congratulations on us very nice very
interesting win so there's a very sharp
game we didn't really give this game
enough justice until the very end but
what do you think were the main critical
moments of this game
see three is like move 18 right yeah so
you think it was better here after see
three because like the a five pound is a
bit weak mhm and here I try to like to
create some code to play with d5 mm-hm
trying to open up the positions and so
he took the opponent before it takes
quintics
yeah yeah maybe in this position instead
of going for that pole maybe he could
have tried a move like Bishop e3 and
then it takes de and then Fe can I take
one might be a bit dangerous
there's some Bishop of 395 and yeah
maybe it's possible but could be because
also there's Knight takes before yeah
okay
so it's certainly this idea t5 was a
very interesting very double-edged but
you know it it definitely worked very
well for you in the game because he took
retakes before kind of leaving the
knight a little bit out of place and
then you know you took token you know
you went for it which takes edge three
which think was a very good move
yeah and it was also like free long time
yeah it was a very practical decision
because it's very hard for him to play
and yeah maybe Bishop of 4595 was
possible but yeah but certainly it's
anyone's game here so it took and you
thought that was going for the perpetual
[Music]
was pretty strong yeah I'm here I think
years like only one move 96 96 to
prevent Bishop e5 and then maybe you
don't have rent also okay to be it row
baby 80 afters and here probably you
have nothing better than making the draw
yeah yeah so 96 was the only move but I
mean no case by the way in this position
there is maybe also a move Knight g4 I'm
not I'm not sure
Bishop takes an queen check
- it takes two h1 and then likes a rock
ft8
okay with like Bishop e5 I did
essentially yeah I mean that's but it
was hard to find Knight takes e4 was the
natural human move yeah but this was
yeah this was a mistake
okay b8 Queen c6 Bishop e5 and now it
looks like you're you're winning
although I'm wondering if he at some
point had yeah I've done this hamster
bomb I see
so Knight g3 this was all very nice
geometry yeah here King G 1 and this
should be 8 yeah I wanted to check on my
son
mm-hmm and rook da yeah this was a yeah
this was a very sharp position so if you
go let's say Bishop c7 Kingdom so there
should be six
I saw 123 king t2 and then maybe 93
something similar to what you had okay
the game and you also maybe have Bishop
a5 ideas maybe a difference
for example if King it - now you have
this Bishop a5 and I ideal that you
didn't have in the game so as possible
at Bishop c7 was slightly more precise
but this should be it was you know very
natural route e8 keeping the tension
certainly a hard position to play and
this is where maybe he had a chance this
was where kind of I was in live
commentary and you know the engine I
don't know if I would have come up with
this move but was finding this routine
okay and then this trip g3 and now the
question is where does he go if he goes
Kim Jiwon you give a check check kingi
194 and in this line your housemates you
have this tripping three and that's why
you could be - to the bishop yeah but of
course you know and time pressures such
things are hard to find even on the
puzzle this might be a sorry
yeah there should be seven here and this
is where he made a decisive mistake you
should have tried to inking it - yeah I
just saw the perpetual and I didn't see
anything to play for a win here I mean
if I force I think I'll maybe lose yeah
I think there might have been some
chances but it's very hard to find yes
so this was like looks like it was one
big missed opportunity to maybe there
was something else besides that as well
in any event but now he made a mistake
with King T - and after 93 now you're
winning you win a broken the problem is
the attack doesn't stop from him anyway
in here and then it's just all she wrote
yeah I mean maybe there was even mate
here instead I say for you but this was
also more than good enough and position
simplifying and he resigned yeah
so very nice finish to your tournament
how many points did you end up with like
four out of nine so but still at least
you finished off with a win so in fact
very nice fighting weird things so any
last-minute thoughts on your tournament
like oh I know you're probably hoping
for much better result so what do you
think kind of went wrong for you I
thought I think like the the level of
play here is pretty much stronger than
in Montreal it's not like one thing it's
like opening preparation and calculation
and people here are pretty much like
more resilient they defend super well
and I think it was great a great
experience to play nice and close and I
want to like thank the Fung Wah who
invited me because he couldn't play in
this tournament it was good experience
and I hope maybe I'll come back and yeah
I think sure I wanted to have the norm
but the darienne's were pretty strong a
deception and
ya know the your players in the u.s. are
are very strong and I mean III know
firsthand eNOS and they take a lot of
rating from me quite a lot as well and
ya know I mean it's certainly a very
tough tournament and you know very
well-spoken very positive approach you
know trying to learn from this
tournament and indeed you know we think
the st. Louis we cannot think enough the
st. Louis just for running these kind of
events great opportunities for young
players like Shikata for getting
invaluable experience against tough
players and having very nice normal
portunities and playing in a nice
round-robin tournament so thanks a lot
for coming here and thanks for sharing
your thoughts and I wish you best of
luck and your I am title and hopefully
you know on your quest of becoming a
strong GM oh that's great okay so you
know what we expect that to happen in
very very soon and hopefully then you
can start working on your GM yeah and
you know you're certainly a great
fighting player I've even played you
want saying I think you're capable of
great things so I wish you and truly all
the best I think once your opening and
calculation improves and I think you
know very great things you know ahead of
you yeah maybe like for Jim I need to
play more solid openings but for now
it's you know it's it's about you know
learning how to fight when you're young
and then it's maybe about you know
improving that you're wrestling you to
get like International Master I think
it's just you need some very good
calculation I don't think you need to
play like you know like solid openings I
mean for for Jim you you have to be
solved for black but I think I just need
to like improve my calculation
in short positions sounds good alright
thanks a lot for coming and take care
and hopefully see you soon things
alright so now we have another guest
coming up another winner of today's
round and that is and that is gonna be
our Rochelle Rochelle was coming okay
okay so Rochelle ended up making a draw
today in a very very long battle against
Peter Gennaro's so will looking forward
to hearing her thoughts on on the
critical moments of of this game so me
it looked like it was a relatively slow
progress in game but then later on the
game kind of got interested when white
went for the c4 and black played c5 and
after that it was a very interesting
sharp fight so without further ado
welcome Rochelle to the studio thanks
for coming so how do you think about
this game it was a very long fighting
control so what it looked like at some
point it was it I didn't really notice
that I was gonna lose a pawn mm-hmm
after you mean so did you see the move
c5 or yeah but I thought after a five
takes takes I only consider G takes I
didn't really realize that after Knight
takes mine I still pinned
yeah because at least here there's
Bishop h6 and you have very good
compensation but unfortunately as Peter
saw after Knight six of six you're still
you look you gave up two points and you
can only gain one point for the piece
and suddenly you're down upon but what
you've done very well in this tournament
is defended very tough positions you
know you've been a very resilient player
yesterday you even turn you're very
prosperous positioning to even turning
the tables completely and winning and
today also you were very resilient now
maybe there were a couple of moments
where both sides could have played
better but in any event practically it
was always not so easy for
maybe he should try this should be six
what were some critical moments where
you think that he could have maybe
played better and at converting I think
I noticed that he had a win later what
was the moment where he played like
Queen c5 was move 37 right you could
have played rook c5 indeed yes and that
actually that move actually is just
complete the winning because black
plates f6 and just there's no way to
defend against losing a piece so you saw
that probably right after you made it
right so I guess 24 would have given you
better drunk chances and where you think
you could have played better to not
allow this winning chance for for white
for black I mean yes so maybe somewhere
around here maybe instead of playing
rook do you wanna complete the ship t4
immediately lift up d4 first yeah if I
wanted to retake the pawn on d5 yeah and
then at Bishop c7 possibly yeah but I
think room do you want might still be
relatively okay but what were your
thoughts about just recapturing right
away so he takes you take with the Queen
let's say and then you sacrifice this
weakness but maybe play move like
Queenie for creating some threats
Queenie 87 yeah that makes sense yeah so
this is not also clear draws so even
here it seems like kind of difficult
defense but still it seems like you
played actually quite okay in this part
of the game here though I mean maybe
there was some better chances maybe like
Queen d5 could could have been a move
it's a little bit counterintuitive I
guess
so you took here and then you took
hereand yeah now you got the pawn back
but it's
ah yes what about if you go Queen c4
here and trying to pin down
not exactly sure why didn't play it I
think I thought it was like risky after
maybe Queen c6 in Queen b7
yeah but looks like then you can try to
just move the rock away and kind of be
actually defending yeah so that was that
looks to be an improvement over Queen of
five because now at least it looks like
Black is kind of controlling I mean here
- it looks like white should still be
close to equal somehow but it looks like
maybe with Queen d5 because after this
Quincy force suddenly this is getting
unpleasant because black is getting
control over the game and now and then
we know what what happened you know
black obviously had this very nice to
win rook c5 freeing this Queen to bring
the rope to defend the Queen and then
coming up with f6 but you know it was a
probably relief that he played Queen C
file
not much surely if it's still a very
difficult position even here and in fact
even here after c4 it looks like with
perfect play he should be somehow
winning but looks like 98 was his chance
still to looks like he's just winning
the piece but yeah he played Knight of a
true c8 and even here it still seems
like c3 maybe was somehow winning but he
really wanted to play it very simple and
suddenly here this endgame maybe he just
assumed this was like very good winning
chance but amazingly enough yeah your
Bishop is just very strong and all his
bones are under a lot of his bones are
in the dark squares and this turns out
to be not so easy to to win an f5 was of
course a very nice move fixing his pawns
on the dark square is a very instructive
move because after this if block gets
this in black will probably be winning
but f5 was a very nice very nice move
here showing very good understanding of
the endgame and now just King comes in
and suddenly
this is not winnable anymore probably
right
c3 King Bishop c2 black does go for some
counter play but this is already kind of
difficult maybe there is one more chance
to try to go for this right away but I'm
not sure if this is leaning anymore this
is a really kind of a race but the way
the game played out it looks like it's
just just the draw from this point on so
yeah any thoughts on the tournament
overall I think I did pretty well for my
first norm tournament I was kind of
expecting to do really bad because I'm
I'm way low-rated than everyone else so
so this was your first ever Norn
tournament like this right well I guess
we don't well I guess not your first
ever very very strong German though
because I remember how well you were
playing at the world teams right where
you're playing a lot of strong players
so at least hopefully that experience
over there helped you kind of ready get
used to these strong players knowing
that they're also human they make
mistakes they give you all the tons of
chances and it's just a matter of you
know getting more experience playing
tournaments like that and I think before
no time you will be you know a regular
guest in these tournaments hopefully
very soon even getting these norms on a
regular basis so very nice tournament
for you and I wish you best of luck in
your upcoming events thank you thanks
for coming all right so let's see if we
have any updates on the Brandon game and
what a surprise it's still going on you
know they're still playing of course
Brandon is still trying so somehow
confuse his opponent but so far his
opponent is not really giving in from
what we could see I don't think that he
he kind of gave an inch to white in
regards to his winning chances so this
still is still is heading towards a draw
and this as I said it's can go as long
as move 120 so you know I wouldn't be
surprised if this game goes as long as
even all the way to the start of the
playoffs today so we never know right
and back
yeah and playoffs are scheduled to start
in just 26 minutes if with a 30-second
increment that these two have right here
it's highly unlikely wouldn't you say
that this is gonna end in anything
except for a draw very unlikely but of
course and now that the king is escaping
to e6 and there's only 23 moves before
move 50 I would say yeah it's not all
that likely that white would win at this
point with the king being centralized
and even if you do somehow stumble into
losing position it still takes at least
like 1012 moves to actually win it so
yeah at this point we can you know say
with almost certainty that this will end
in that drop for those of you who don't
know the 50 move rule is 50 moves that's
a move for white and move for black
that's one whole move so one hundred
half moves since the last pawn push or
the last capture of any material on the
board so that's where that move 70 comes
in that's when the last pond was
captured from the board yeah so we're
gonna be on here until we're gonna be on
the air until the end of this game and
then we'll take a short break before
4:00 p.m. Central Time where we will see
Danish Boros square off against Jackson
Bulli AK for the championship of the
Grand Master norm field and the $2,000
that goes along with it
yeah so very exciting round I mean you
know Eric made a game out of this from a
very tough position against the Keeton
Keeton eventually you know got the draw
but it was game down to the wire and in
the GM Lawrence tournament Jackson buuck
won a very clutch game against Andrew
Huang you know from position which
looked like not very prospect lists at
some point it looked like very little
hope because he made a mistake he made a
miscalculation but he found a way to
keep the game going and once Andrew
slipped up just a little bit he took
advantage of his chances and then took
some advantage of all those
opportunities and that's what champions
are made of and you know very deserving
win for Jack and should be a very fun
you know interesting playoff between two
very not interesting players Denish and
Jack two very fighting GM's let's take a
look at the final standings keep an eye
on this game here in case it ends but
the final statements for the
International master norm event because
we know we can show you now from the
bottom up
Arron Korbin ski and Peter Gennaro's
walk away with four hundred dollars each
Rochelle Wu Ezra chambers Aaron Jacobson
and Kenta chiku rate' since they all tie
with four points each they leave with
$425 Eric Rosen and Gauri Shankar
sharing third place six hundred and
fifty dollars each second place Luis
Torres with $1,000 and our champion we
heard from him earlier Keeton Kyra
$1,200 leaving st. Louis closing the
gates on all of the hopefuls
nobody's getting the norm in this event
okay let's uh let's glance back at the
game yeah so now we still have the
second ranked defense but now from the
other side now from you know earlier we
had it like over there and like near the
eighth-ranked but now we're having it
from the second and first ring so it's
like the board has flipped over like 90
degrees but it's still the same second
ranked defense and now we're up to 106
so white only has 14 moves remained
remaining to potentially make progress
and Brandon is desperately looking for
some miracle way to make it work but of
course it's gonna be very very difficult
to do so and I'm just playing with the
numbers in my head and I know that gets
me in trouble sometimes but what exactly
Justin and Brandon are fighting for here
Brandon currently sits with three points
and Justin with five
so it looks like Brandon is the one
who's fighting here for more money I
don't actually I think it's probably
Justin because Brandon even if he wins
you probably will still finish in the
second half where he'll probably get
almost the same amount of money
regardless Justin on the other hand you
know he's he is a five out of eight so I
think for him the difference or might
not make a difference for either one of
them actually because all those prizes
in the bottom half they're typically the
same right yeah so Justin cannot win
those games so best-case scenario he
draws so if he gets five and a half Jack
and Dennis arts out six and a half and
is there anyone else at five right now
let's say no one else is at five no one
else is at five one else is at five this
is the only one at five ah so that's
that means Justin if he gets five he
would get a clear third anyway yeah okay
so actually then they're only playing
for rating points probably yeah
interestingly enough okay okay but still
for young players it's very important
also bragging rights right you know so
young players potentially will be
competing with each other in many future
events so definitely I know they both
wanna you know not given yeah I mean two
three youngest players in the field
competing right now just in weighing is
just 13 years old from Katy Texas I
think that's in the Houston metro area
he Justin actually has had really good
performance here in st. Louis before I
remember interviewing him in studio a
very soft-spoken and I just the other
players could not figure out how to get
past this guy he was wearing the hat
back then and it was the Hat kid but yet
Justin Wang and Brandon Jacobson 15
years old the younger of the Jacobs
Jacobson brothers from New York City
fighting for rating points well either
players slip up here
we'll about we're about to find out but
well for white it's very hard to slip up
but you know black still defending
successful and now only 12 moves to go
so I wonder what happens first this game
finishes or the playoff starts yeah well
and hopefully they don't have to move
the playoff back anymore for those of
you who are joining us the playoff is
gonna be at 4 p.m. Central Time just
about 20 minutes away and it will be
seen at us chess champs calm you'll have
the digital board there and everything
and we'll be able to provide it to you
here on the show as well so while we're
waiting for these guys to wrap it up
might as well tell you about some
upcoming events here at the st. Louis
chess club and beyond we have the summer
chess Classic coming up on June 18th the
first day of that will be producing that
right here from Studio B at the st.
Louis Club and it's going to be the
strongest summer chess classic ever well
we love reminiscing about the u.s.
championship but the Summer Classic is
going to be the strongest classic yet we
have four of them a year our seasonal
classic series kind of like this only no
norms necessarily on the line there are
some no impossibilities every now and
then but it is a step up in competition
after the summer classic we have Summer
Classic u.s. chess champs calm of course
Croatia look next classical stop on the
grand chest for one of two classical
tournaments this year on the grand chest
or the other being of course the
Ziegfeld Cup Croatia happens starting
June 26th that's at grande chest tour
org and Croatia is going to be notable
because the only time you'll see all 12
full tour competitors competing in the
same events will be in st. Louis for the
Sinquefield Cup and in Croatia which is
a brand new addition to the grand chest
or the second leg this year second leg
of seven regular events to classical
five rapid and blitz and then of course
the eighth event the final in London
in December and then after that we have
a brand new addition to an already
existing event a brand new tournament
it's the u.s. senior junior and girls
championship three tournaments all
happening at the same time the senior
closed is a brand-new event the first
time we're having it we're gonna party
like it's the US Championship in 2005
it's gonna be a lot of fun and that
begins on July 11th okay any any news on
the game uh nope brendan is still
desperately figuring out how to maybe
create some trick you know that's black
and fall for some desperate last-minute
chance they're only 12 moves to go
before move fifty so it's looking almost
hopeless but Brandon is just not willing
to give up trademark of a true champion
player future to be champion let's see
might be worth to look closer at the
board oh well Justin just got up now
he's back yeah Brandon really looks
upset here he sees that it's not gonna
be very likely that he will make
progress and you know we very well know
that he messed up actually let's see
where exactly he blew because last time
we looked at the per game
he was completely winning right when we
left off here king centralized d5 pawns
are pushing it's completely winning it
should be completely winning these six
everything is still fine here and now
black found a very nice trick rookie for
Sakurai zhing the whole rook well what
else otherwise the pawns will just you
know it's it's an express train with
these pawns right so rookie four takes
rook takes at least he gets rid of both
of these pawns or obi-wan that was still
a good move trying to prepare for a four
now a four is dealt with Ruby Tzu
so King see four was played Roxy to
check King T three rook c8 and rook c8
turned out to be a huge blunder actually
it looks like a very logical move in
fact Lee comes with a maiden to threat
rogue t1 check and then mate but after
look of six check respects f4 Bishop d2
suddenly there's no more aware
because if you go root beats for three
you go King D four check King stood for
and the rook hangs on on on b3 and the
same thing happens here King sits who
the rook Hanks and otherwise you lose
the bishop and you lose you know then
you're just up in exchange with black
has now too dangerous pawns and you know
again you're not winning so this was a
huge blunder that Brandon has made here
rooks see it looks very tempting but he
missed his opponent's idea I mean in
this position probably a lot of ways to
win I mean roof chi-su keeping the
tension g6 maybe route g5 step by step
this somehow should be winning the
points aren't really going anywhere it's
very hard to push the points with the
roofs controlling like if you go here
you can just check and take on a four
for example and if a four you can give a
check here but this is where he blew all
his advantage because now he is
basically forced to play this rook and
Bishop best-case scenario that was
actually I mean he somehow he managed to
get rid of all these bones but even here
by the way it looks like there was still
some chances for example here blacks
best move was to take and go King sits
ooh he was probably afraid of check King
tip 3 rooks itsu kicks it to h5 but
actually this is a this is still a draw
takes takes h6 a4 and bones will promote
white will promote but you know clock
goes 8 2 and this is a theoretical draw
as we were very well know but root D 2
is played and now if white would've gone
King e6 I don't actually see how black
would have tried to draw this game
because of rope here here and let's say
King c1 you can give check and then
rugby 5 so I'm not totally sure what
what why didn't like your maybe King c2
but then you can take this take this
take this and this is just the winning
row component game but white but King
Steve for and now rookie to was a strong
move
and now he went for this but rookie
foreign is just the draw so looks like
even in the endgame Brandon had the
chance even after he made a mistake but
then we were left with this rook and
Bishop again stroke which is now at this
position nine moves away and just the
matter of countdown before this game
will end in the draw have you ever
played to a 50 move force draw oh you
know I've definitely had that many times
before where I've had like let's say a
position which God and then to a 50 move
I'm sure at some point it happened more
than once probably but I don't remember
when it was last time that happened but
I definitely know that it's happened
before I mean in fact I think I remember
I was once defending in the world opener
okay broken bishop construe pagainst Roe
from Ed of which I defend very
successfully I don't remember if you
played all 50 moves or he played 50 or
40 or whatever but I'm sure it's
happened and also in some small terms I
remember I had my crooked Bishop and
stroke and I remember at some point it
was 50 moves I couldn't win it was a
it's actually ironic because rookin
Bishop construc I played against the
local 2,300 player once the marshal and
we're playing pretty much on the
five-second delay and he knew it just
very very well and I never got a single
chance to win the game but yet when I
was playing the 2700 feet a player in an
increment tournament in an official
tournament somehow he didn't really know
it so then then I somehow managed to win
that game so it's one of these things
that it doesn't matter what your actual
chest level is it's either you know it
or you don't
that's what it comes down so it's just
pure knowledge it's like Bishop a knight
again Bishop a knight checkmate Bishop
Knight King against King you know it's
one of these things which sometimes the
1200 might know how to do it but
sometimes you know you've seen GM's not
know how to do it so it's just one of
these weird things where either you know
it or you don't
and in this case it looks like Justin
Wang knows exactly how to defend and and
now we don't even the board doesn't seem
to even go further besides move
1:12 it seems like this game is going so
long that even this is even the
technical side is now betray I'm up to
114 so we'll have to check in on that
but let's get a closer look at the board
yep there it is expecting a draw yeah
six moves away six moves away in 10
minutes before the playoffs so we wonder
what happens first ma'am this is so I
mean what could what could the players
be thinking here like her well those
hoping for freaks at this point yes I
mean at this point Brandon is just
hoping for a random slip I mean at this
point there's really no even practical
oh yeah because for example if black
didn't do anything white was threatening
room she won't skewer but of course that
was a childish trap at this point well
their children well that is technical
that is true there are under age of 18
so technically but certainly very strong
kids who are capable of beating any
Grandmaster any point so you know and
this gets me thinking it's a reminds me
of the u.s. Junior Championship coming
up you know the first time I was I had
the privilege of being a part of that
great tournament producing the show was
2015 and ever since then and it'll be
the fifth year already that this team
was worked on the US Junior Championship
I don't have the roster yet I don't even
know if it's confirmed yet but I have a
feeling that both of these guys might be
playing I have a feeling especially
Brendan unless he declined he certainly
how would have qualified by rating I
mean it's yeah UCF is almost 2,600 his
speed is over 25
I feel like Justin it's close whether he
made it by rating or not but there's a
chance that even he will also be
participating
yeah there's a chance I mean we're
looking at two top American Juniors rate
the thing about the junior though is if
you compare let's say the junior these
years compared it's almost as strong as
let's say a US Championship let's say 12
years ago let's say back in 2007 let's
say it's almost as strong
basically it's as hard to get this here
basically to get into just to get into
this year's US Junior it's probably as
hard as let's say with the rating that
would require to get into the US Junior
you would be like a clear favorite to
win it outright like 10 12 years ago do
you know what I mean like yeah 2500 UCF
25 50 is like probably route to the
cutoff to just get into the u.s. junior
by rating this would be a clear favorite
this kind of player to win let's say 10
12 years ago man has times changed yeah
I mean US Championships same story thing
yeah
same story I mean I'm 2700 UCF but I
feel like unless I get to 2750 UCF I
will not get in by rating and you know
12 years ago 2700 years CF player would
be one of the favorites to win the
championship not just to get in the
championship so that's how times have
changed and basically the criteria to
just get into something is is almost
harder than like with that same career
it's like win the event I pulled up the
standings from last year's Junior
Championships just to see where we had
we had 10 competitors and the lowest
ranked competitor in terms of USCF
reading was 23 80 fours anyway so that's
that's the bar guys that's the bar for
the US junior last year at least we'll
see when that happens on July 11th round
1 kicks off at us chest champs calm the
US junior girls and senior championships
so while we're waiting any updated by
the way I'm really close here what's
playing in the
us juniors and seniors yet or we don't
know the fields yet I've heard some
rumblings but nothing that I'm
authorized to disclose fortunately and
what about the st. Louis classic the
summer classic the summer classic what I
can tell you right now is we are gonna
have the strongest classic we've ever
had and we've had what Gaga and you
already have some very strong ones we're
even shook played that like one gleam
played yes this one's gonna be even
stronger Wow yeah I'm looking forward to
you know seeing the games them 75,000
dollars in prize money for the summer
class oh and finally there it is Brandon
gave up the ghost they all made a buck
and that was and that was a game all
right well before we take just a couple
of minutes here before our playoff let's
take a look at our grand master norm
standings and see where we have come so
far there it is at the very top boorish
and schtum bully act will be playing in
mere moments in a two-game rapid match
game in ten with a two monstrous or of
seven out of nine impressive score in
such as field very impressive one and a
half points clear of the whole field
dominated the field for the uninitiated
I'd like to go over the playoff
structure here it's just a best of two
match game in ten with a two second
delay to enter one leaves and we can
guarantee that because if the two game
rapid match does not solve the puzzle
then we will go to a five-minute vs.
4-minute blitz Armageddon where in the
event of a draw Black has given me not
the nod because white has a time
advantage five minutes versus four
minutes we'll get to that just a moment
we're gonna take a brief intermission
and we get back in just a couple minutes
it's playoff time don't go anywhere
we'll see you soon
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello chefs fans and welcome back to
playoff coverage for the 2019 st. Louis
norm Congress we're talking about the
Grand Master norm section two players
remain and it's a rapid match let's take
a look at the players in the hall and
see if they've begun No
yes here they go the handshake and we
are off Dennis burrows has white in the
first game this is best of two rapid
game in ten with a two second delay
there's opponent Jackson in Bulli AK
with the black pieces both players have
seven points the winner will be our
champion so maybe we get a closer look
at the board while we're waiting for the
moves to come in I don't know yeah um so
so far we have but here it's yeah let's
have a closer look for now because the
moves are not over okay so we have a
kind of a oh yeah we have a kind of a
London system Hybrid compiled combined
with Knight c3 against the Bishop g7 I
against the Kings Indian idea and yeah
it's a very ambitious line by white so
Dennis just saying that yeah he's going
for a very nice interesting fight
unconventional gay game and in this
tournament Danish has gone for a lot of
interesting lines in this tournament
like truly for you know interesting
fights and he that's has served him well
in this tournament and he continues to
do that and jack has also played very
good sound chess has calculated very
good chess in this turf has calculated
very very well in this tournament and
[Music]
showing very good form so he's playing
principled playing stuff he knows best
and hoping for the best so far it looks
like White's knowing the line a little
bit better because he's playing
extremely quickly so part he only used
three seconds not counting the delay
whereas jack is kind of burning a little
bit more of time along the way so it
does look like white is a little bit
more comfortable but I would say
position is still roughly equal
certainly black is not worse anyone's
game so there's been a few more moves
that has been played and h4 h5 black has
played a four a six and and we basically
have a very complex game both sides are
having reasonably well placed pieces so
it's a matter of who maneuvers better
and who calculates better and who makes
the last mistake because since such a
time control it's about it's about being
in a better form and you know not making
the kind of the last blunder and I would
say you black sort of solved the opening
problem to some extent I would say he's
definitely not worse but we're not
getting moves though some reason again
oh oh sorry we are
so this is our currently updated
position so black has played 94 and
white has played Queens III challenging
that night there were certain other
interesting ways of playing flight which
takes d4 and Queen e2 but Queen XIII so
far both sides have been playing a very
logical principle chess and this is
exactly what we want to see by the two
leaders of the tournament
so let's see what plan blog goes for so
he went for night 63 it was also
possible to go for takes takes takes
takes and then 95 trying to take
advantage of the sweetness but Knight c3
is also very much viable option and now
white is thinking to take back with the
port opening of the V file and
controlling the sea Foursquare more or
taking back with the Queen
keeping the bone structure intact and
maybe trying to improve the position of
the Queen sooner right now Danish is
thinking about these possibilities and
if you notice also that Danish is
playing very quickly so far Jack is
taking a little bit more time and he
confidently took beat 63 feeling that
this will be kind of in his favor
opening up the the B file and maybe also
more importantly capturing toward the
center in order to potentially prepare C
for black played Knight 65 there was
also this very unconventional option of
Bishop xt5 meeting did this one would
Knight c5 and kind of saying that what
exactly can you do with the dark scores
but this is of course very hard to play
in a blitz game very unconventional so
95 d5 is a very human way to play and
now we have just some kind of a
interesting position Ben what do you
think about this so far well I've
actually been looking at some of the
statistics on these players you know
this is the only the second meeting
between the two they played in the
second round of regulation it was a draw
but something interesting happens when
you switch the time control to rapid and
I'm talking about a ratings difference
here that is a little bit surprising
borish comes in at 24 39 feet a
classical which we've been using for
this event jack is coming in at a 25 16
feet a classical he's favored slightly
by the numbers
by about 80 points but when we switch it
to rapid with feed a rapid ratings Boros
has a 2566 while still bully AK has 2444
so it's completely flipped and boorish
yet I saw him down here in the basement
he looked very comfortable going into
this rapid playoff I wonder if he thinks
he has an edge besides being white of
course yeah very well possibly could be
it may maybe he practices rapid and
blitz quite a lot
after all he studied at Webster for a
long time and there you have a chance to
potentially practice against a lot of
great players who are very good at rapid
and certainly have a chance to if
nothing else just get a better feeling
of how to play like quicker and more
confidently right when you have a chance
to always play against 2600 players
certain allure and learn quite a lot I
have a question here about Jack's
position Jack's just played rook to d8
why not just cancel on the Queen side
that's a very good question
so black castles on the Queen side a
white was planning to take the pawn on
d5 now if you just let the phone sit
here then you're just gonna be losing a
board with a bad position so black wants
to take but then hoops this little porn
you're Hanks so you cannot have this
born on a six unguarded that's why this
a4 a6 early on maybe was a very
interesting inclusion for for white and
that's why Rudy eight has been played
and now okay you could still win the
pawn of course but now it's not gonna be
so scary because after you win the poor
you can win the pawn but good luck now
you're gonna lose the spawn and you're
gonna get pretty heavily attacked here
winter king exposed so it's not the same
effect as if it would have come with a
chip on a6
that's where Ruby g8 was quite good and
Denis porous plate rogue t1 repairing CD
and he is willing to exchange his side
form for the central pawn on d5
and black hair played the move c6
defending everything but now the
drawback is potentially this pawn on d6
becomes a little bit of a target and now
it's Dennis's turn to figure out what
you want to do about it
in fact rugby one here might be very
very logical now the block we can the b6
for how are you going to defend against
it and let's see what move rook be one
would be pawn be forced to push well if
you otherwise what else can you how else
can you defend against that if you go
Queen c7 suddenly you're getting hit by
e6 you know bishop attacks the Queen
porns attacks of seven your King becomes
in big trouble
so b5 would almost be forced and after
CDC DCB you're probably winning a pawn
instead another very interesting option
km Queen b3 b5 but this might be a
little bit less accurate somehow because
now you don't have two attackers on the
b5 point unlike if you would have played
Ruby one so possibly the more
counterintuitive Ruby one move might
have been a bit better here it looks
like black sort of has things at least
somewhat under control so here it looks
like black positionally is fine but of
course now it's already getting to the
mid point of the game where both players
are winding down so around 5 minutes
with still a lot of complexity in the
game so this game we expect to go down
to the wire and again whoever makes the
last second-to-last blunder sort of
speak wins yeah and this isn't like what
we've been seeing so far with the 30
second increment this is a lot different
very tempo second delay yeah you the
only thing that saves you from is you
know not losing on time basically but in
a completely drawn or a winning position
but of course if it's even a little
complicated 2 seconds is absolutely
nothing to help you so a couple moves
have been played here
pawns are exchanging on the B file
yep
yes so it looks like black kind of kind
of stabilized things so Ruby one was
really I think better than Queen b3
because now okay after councils these
six it looks like black is kind of
stabilizing and now it's onus is on
white to try to create something and if
black complete the consolidates then you
know white has to also worry about the
pawn on e5 and it's not so easy so black
you know naturally castled away and
white councils so both sides cancelled
and now it's now it's why it's actually
getting a long time because white now
needs to find a way to create something
in this position and it's not so easy
actually so he tried the move
rugby one now a little bit too late and
now black has a chance to play move like
Bishop c6 defending everything which
came in an instant because already at
this point blacks position is easier to
play and he's anticipating opponents
moves in advance and then that was met
quickly by rooty one thinking about
maybe playing e4 and now white is
potentially putting pressure on both
weaknesses but objectively speaking
black is doing completely fine now
so definitely mischance there that he
didn't play room b1 earlier instead of
Queen b3 I wonder just as a production
aspect here I know we have two cameras
up in the tournament hall or the other
camera gets a fuller view of the board
yes now white is you know applying more
pressure on that b5 point what this
should be too so let's see if black just
a fencer that's very possible that you
can defend it but he can also maybe try
to sacrifice it okay well he put Queen
c7 a very logical move counter-attacking
on the five point you know so he's
willing to give up to be five point but
then he can either win the c2 pawn or d5
pawn black has absolutely no promise
here I would say black from practical
standpoint view I like black hole bit
more because just somehow blacks
position looks more pleasant to play
white also has a weaknesses and blacks
moves are a bit easier to plan and
Dennis just you know went with a very
aggressive approach Bishop g5 but I
moves fine he wants to go Bishop of six
and create some problems so that moves
still fine trying to really take care of
the weakness of 195 makes a lot of sense
so now I'm wondering if black wants to
take stock exchange or anything like
that probably not because to be 5.0
those two behind King me so probably a
rook a eight is logical getting the rook
to the open file and then white played
f4 yeah F force of course double edged
but again it's to defend the spawn but
maybe now rook c8 Bishop e8 and black
now starts getting control over the game
so a4 is definitely double-edged there
was also bishop of six MLA after f4 now
I mean the bishops fate on g5 is clearly
written yeah it's I mean it could still
you know live
I mean g4 h5 might come at some point I
mean I think White's playing and
viciously he's trying to play for an
attack but it means I'm there maybe okay
no moves have been OK ROCK a1 has been
played trying to neutralize they file if
white would have taken that then maybe
you could take and take on c2 and black
is comfortable so he tried her ok one
and let's see what Jack did Jack played
another good move Bishop f8 he saw that
the bishop on g7 doesn't do anything
anymore here so he's trying to
reposition it to more better prospects
where it has better prospects I would
say at this point Black has a clear
advantage but of course it's three you
know three minutes and change each
anything can of course happen in this
game but black is clearly doing well so
let's see is he gonna play g4 no he's
playing Bishop f6 first he's playing
Bishop f6 first but again they're really
just no threats black can you even play
like before rotate for rotate three now
and start really dominating and he
reached out for the pawn before and he
sees the idea okay three
and you know we can just see how
confident jack is right now playing in
very good form just seizing these
opportunities like he is just using his
pieces to the best of his ability I mean
we saw how he won the Lasky and just an
excellent form in this tournament and
Dennis has played g4 going for it
because what else otherwise he's just
gonna lose slowly in the queenside
so he has tore at this point though all
or nothing but at this point objectively
speaking you know even though white
might be you know looking for it you
know even though this might be losing
this g4 stuff but you know it's if
you're gonna you know lose you might as
well lose soundly not slowly right if
you if you die you might as well die
soundly I mean the idea of a Burroughs
pushing through on the kingside here
looking for something I think it's
pretty exciting very exciting yeah it's
5:00 and stuff but it objective it with
perfect play blocks should be block
should be better so let's see what move
you played this block player move yet or
is he still thinking here black probably
has several moves okay three is probably
promising maybe Queen b6 start attacking
this problem for white as his own king
is also kind of weak so that's kind of
you know makes things makes the attack
not as attractive but of course it's one
of these positions where one slip-up and
the game can really still turn so I
would not be surprised by any result
here but objectively black is in control
let's see what move was played so the
move played was Bishop d7 so he's
basically threatening the 1 and C 2 and
also safeguarding from any kind of a5
ideas it was better here to play Bishop
maybe b7 but it's not clear why probably
because after rook e8 you can now take
with the rook and then go here and at
some point maybe there are t4 ideas and
Queen c6 but Bishop d7 seems like a very
natural human move which also seems very
good
and now Dan is just thinking about how
to really continue here and I mean h5
would be the natural way to follow but
then you're just gonna take and take our
seats ooh and again where exactly is the
attack it's probably prepared for h5
takes and takes on on g6 to defend this
pawn and maybe at some point go king of
seven so in fact it's still very hard
for white do anything so Bishop d7 was
also very good move very good practical
move seems like black still has
everything very much in control and now
white is despot of thinking desperately
finding a way to try to create some
practical shrine you found nothing
better than to go h5 you know and now
black can just take on a1 and take on c2
it looks like okay and he did that
no he played rook takes a 1 ok and after
Luke takes a 1 he probably will play Cup
yeah he took on c2 that's exactly what
happens and now black is just have a
pawn and in and it's gonna be an endgame
because white actually cannot possibly
avoid the Queen trade so at this point
it looks very desperate for white
meaning it's probably just lost Queen
texty to rook takes to - everything is
just very nice the defendant for black
and the poorness you know basically a
couple of squares away from really
becoming the decisive factor there's
just absolutely nothing white can do
even moves like rook a7 they don't
really help because I you should still
go b2 b3 b2 and then you go to c1 and
you win material so black try it hg of a
cheap but that doesn't help much either
he's 6 is a little bit weak okay so he
desperately tries for ok 7 but now you
can even just go Bishop c8 keeping
everything in control and that's exactly
what happened
Bishop c8 and now the pawn will not go
away anywhere the porn will be a couple
of moves from queening and the black
rook mc2 is basically played placed
perfectly and there was one moment
though if you actually play carelessly
like this like I mentioned before you
actually get made it so bishops see it
was very important and conveniently it
vents any kind of rugby seven so there
was some moves played rukka eight the
ships okay seven here and then he took
on c8 took on e6 King h7 it would have
won a piece but of course the problem is
if you take on c8 you don't if you would
have taken on c8 you lose because b2 and
you cannot stop the pawn because they're
five squares can control by the g6
square black has just promoted and black
has just promoted and actually in this
position now after Bishop takes d5 beet
soup there should be four of c1 king of
two Queen you know when our just upper
rook you know White has a couple of
points for it but really it's you know
very simple technique from here and now
we're all the way in this position but
yeah this should be pretty simple Bishop
e7 bish 54 at least trying to control
the b6 square so that you don't win the
pawn right away but simply King g8 and
many ways to win ruby 5 was played and
with one minute on the clock with two
second delay I expect blacks easily
convert this position and that would put
Dennis in a must-win game with black and
but as we know that Dennis is not
foreign to these kind of situations he
won a very nice must win a game against
Casa Corley you know kept the tension
kept the tension and eventually once so
if anyone can do it it's him
so I'm sure that you know he will do his
best and it could still be anyone's
anyone's tournament even after this but
this game in the meantime is looking
very bad for for white and it's just a
matter of time before blacks should be
able to convert it if you're watching us
on YouTube get active in the chat I've
got the chat open talk to us send us
some questions send us your pics and
your prognosis for this game and also us
chess champs calm if you're watching on
YouTube to see the digital board still
have one more game guaranteed after this
yam blocks plan a simple King h5 kimchi
for
to take on a four and yeah why just
cannot do very much in this position so
what did white try so what was by king d
- King h5 king C - but now we can just
play rook f3 probably or roof before you
played prophase six I think no okay
three here and then rupees six and
there's a handshake Jack's tabouli AK
has won Game one he is the victor one
two zero for him and if it's not tied
one to one after this game then he's the
champ Boros has one more shot to tie it
up yeah so a very impressive game by a
jack right here I mean winning with
black I mean you know it looked like
wife was very comfortable in the opening
kind of do what he was doing but you
know black to his credit you know spent
a little bit of time defendant quite
well in the opening and then when white
missed a couple of opportunities to get
a slight advantage black was all over
him you know and then the critical
moment was somewhere around some around
here and you know this plan with Bishop
g5 of for was very ambitious but of
course to also kind of left behind maybe
some dark square control and already
here after Bishop f8 and before suddenly
turned out of blocks initiative when the
Queen side was quicker and the whites
attack on the king said just never came
to the fruition and black just
calculated everything precisely and
continues to show his impressive form in
this term in your opinion was f4 the
death knell for Danish Boris um well
it's possible that it was a mistake I
mean maybe Bishop f6 was better to trade
off this Bishop because as we know later
on that Bishop came self Aiden became a
very important factor if you would have
traded it off and then played a for
maybe that would've first of all
increased as attacking chances but more
importantly it would have you know slow
down blacks counter play because that
Bishop from it f8 really control a lot
of key squares porn before rukon a3 that
Bishop on a fade became like a sleeper
which became like a very important
factor layer
the game in the beginning it was a
sleeper but later it proved to be a very
powerful piece later on whereas after
Bush was six okay even if you take this
yes your porn will be weak but the pawn
on d5 is also weak and after something I
queen c3 you also have to watch out for
some g4 ideas as well so this is you
know not all that clear so I think yes
a4 was a very double-edged ambitious
move but it looks like his attack just
never came into fruition and from there
black kind of just took control by
playing very very precise just a couple
of questions here in the question in a
comment in the chat
Shruthi asked instead of Bishop f8 could
there have been rook a4 instead of
Bishop f8 could there have been Roque
for in this position very well possibly
yeah rope a4 also looks like a very
promising move actually what ideal after
Luke takes a 4 ba and the bishop takes
b5 takes take some rugby 8 and you're
gonna win the piece because C 4 is met
by this move so yeah okay four would
have also been a very interesting
alternative but Bishop f8 was also good
move and now we are underway with the
second game of this playoff two games
two game matchup game in 10 two second
delay it's a must-win situation for
Denis burrows with the black pieces yeah
and let's see what oh yeah now we yeah
so there we go we're we're off here and
the naturally after c4 black played c6
and c5 Bishop g7 again systems with g6
our systems which we often play when we
need to win so certainly make sense for
Denis trying to keep the game kind of
unbalanced and kind of keep him at a
little bit of a distance knight c6 yeah
and then he or y just decided to play a
quiet system with e3 which makes sense
it's not all that ambitious but it's
also not bad considering that he just
needs a draw to win the tournament so
but certainly it's good for black as
well because it's certainly is still a
position with lots of pieces on the
board certainly position where chances
could be created so I would say both
sides are somewhat happy but I would say
black probably won the opening battle
because basically black was able to
a comfortable position but also not
being worse but also with winning
chances keeping pieces on the board
where things are not just simplified
into a draw so I would say the opening
worked kind of well for black but also
I'm sure why it's not too unhappy as
well so why does just trade it off
Knights is this standard practice in
this opening this is not like the
typical position you see in this game in
fact like probably if I was right here
I would probably play E for 45 more
principled but I guess you know Jack
decided to just you know play a very
simple position not trying to do too
much and just you know putting his
pieces into good square so maybe he
knows something about the system that I
don't wear maybe white gets a little bit
easier play I mean he wants to go b3 but
should be - and just kind of similar to
the way Eric rose and played against
Keaton but difference though being the
pawn on e3 controls with the Foursquare
so black never actually gets control
over the d4 square
unlike Keaton did in the game against
Eric Rosen so I would say yeah in this
position black is comfortable but so is
white so it's just one of these games
where probably both sides are kind of
happy with the opening outcome to be
honest Ryan Murphy notes that white is
playing very safe yeah well good reason
for that good reason for that yeah he
just needs a drawer but he's not
necessarily playing for a draw like he
did unbalanced the structure with 966
he's just playing the type of position
where he knows the plans and you know he
knows how to play the position but it
doesn't mean he's playing for a draw
it's just playing something he feels
like he knows reasonably well and in a
rapid time control that's what you got
to do you got to just play what what you
know best I think because you don't have
time to think and you gotta just be able
to play quick natural moves you played
in a u.s. championship playoff was that
rapid it was yeah well basically I
played in the three-way playoff actually
was between me gotta camps ganbara
Cobian 2014 9 2014 yes and unfortunately
for me I had the worst tiebreaks because
I ended up I lost in the regular
head-to-head match against cad/cam skin
Andrew vara Cobian so as a result I had
the worst hybrid so I had to play
against var : and Armageddon just to get
into this two-man player and I end up
losing their Armageddon game Suvari
Cobian and then mark open of course lost
to Guerra come ski in the end as we
probably know so it was one of these
where unfortunately yeah didn't quite go
my way but I mean I can only blame
myself because certain I had very good
chances to win outright in earlier in
the tournament you know rounds 10 or 11
at some point in fact that played vara
koban in the last round was white and I
had a very promising position out of the
opening but truth to be told later I
miss plated so battle that also Varco
beam was much better and he definitely
also would have regrets over this
tournament of not winning outright so
it's like a very epic finish where the
leaders played each other in the last
round I always love that have a sporting
question though for you it let's say
you're one of these two players the norm
tournaments don't always have playoffs
maybe it's like a newer trend but as for
you if you're finishing with seven out
of nine points do you want to play in a
playoff for first place
uh-huh well I think if I would have
scored seven out of nine I would be
hoping that I would win clear first yeah
it'll be quite honest yeah with such a
good score but yeah if I score that well
and I end up playing a playoff and I
lose then okay it's just what to do you
know somebody maybe somebody else always
has to get a bit more lucky and a bit
more fortunate as we saw with Jack's
Cape today that game clearly could have
gone either way so you know it's one of
these things where first place is kind
of sometimes I feel like you need a
little bit extra almost like luck to get
first place but I feel like if you're in
very good form you're almost guaranteed
to get second or third but you didn't
really answer the question that was a
really good not answer Alex I mean would
you prefer to play in a playoff or not
if you were one of these guys it's up to
you you can have the tie oh I feel a
dispute
first oh I see what you're saying yeah
actually I think playoff was good yes
okay I I just didn't understand no I
would I would prefer there to be a
playoff yes I think from a sporting
stand point of view that would be that's
more fun like that yeah
even though I kind of lost Alan because
I would have been a co champion
otherwise it's like 2,000 or something
yeah co-champion a like winnaman how
about that yeah I would have been but
you know it's it is what it is it's okay
and I I'm sure I'll still have my
chances you know later in my career as
long as I keep doing the right things
for my chest I feel like I'll still have
chances so I'm not I'm not discouraged
so Boris just pressed c5 yeah all night
a to c5 yeah that's so so very
double-edged I mean you could have also
taken but in general I mean this very
complex game in White's trying to play
here on the Queen side you know blocks
trying to kind of hold forth but it
looks like whites now kind of getting
control over the game from what I could
see Knight c3 and just kind of getting
though a very nice position here from
what I could see the Knights come to d5
white at some point will push the ape on
the b-pawn looks like white has made
progress playing on the Queen side
whereas the black hasn't really made too
much progress on other side so it looks
like white is the one who made more
progress in the last few moves what do
you think I don't disagree I'm not gonna
disagree with you but okay so I just
noticed that f5 has been pushed this
looks like the dark square black Bishop
is is looking pretty nasty right now and
a good way for black yeah yeah yeah I
mean that's just one very good piece but
you know why does have a lot of space on
the Queen side though and after move
like 95 maybe trying to exchange one of
the bishops it still seems like it's
gonna be very hard for block to create
winning chances I mean I think if
anyone's all the better it's it's white
he played the move Queen b3 first which
maybe is a little inaccurate I mean
honestly 95 right away not sure what he
didn't like here maybe he didn't like 96
but
after buffet three f-35 the night gets
kicked away and at some point King H
Swan fouled by e4 might be played and he
seven might be week - bishop advance the
1395 was a good move and assertive
Queens e8 sorry about our Queens e8 and
maybe a move like a five could be
something to consider or even Bishop c3
but okay Queen b3 was played that's also
fine bishop d8 it's like a typical move
you see sometimes in a Dutch you know
just kind of building your harmony a
little bit and kind of bringing the
bishop back maybe freeing the poem for
some from some things Bishop of three
Queen c8 so black is kind of keeping the
tension here hoping for the best what is
going in blacks favor here is the time
advantage once again Daniel is playing
very quickly
his only minute use two minutes on the
clock where's Jackson Bullock is down so
ready five minutes just to you know half
his time remained but as we've seen he
is very good even when it comes to time
pressure so certainly I would still say
white is a very big favorite to win the
tournament but it's still a position
where both sides have chances and here
we go
black is the first one who really is
gone for it played g5 very ambitious
move
if pawn takes maybe like some e6000 up
so black decided to kind of go for it
well what else does he have you know he
has no other really active plan and he
needs to win the game so makes a lot of
sense to go for it here I was wondering
you know if he moves back if Bosh was
maybe moving a little too quickly I mean
if White has the edge here but yet bore
OSHA is up three minutes as black is he
moving too quickly but I think maybe you
just answered that question keeping the
tension there yeah well I mean again
it's in a rapid game it's hard to
criticize you know playing so quickly
unless your blunder I mean you pretty
much have to plan your intuition and
play the way you understand the position
I think it's not the issue of playing so
quickly I think it's just an issue of
who understands the structural but
better and who's finding the subtleties
and I mean if I think so far is kind of
a level game I mean here maybe Bishop c6
was better but 55 I'm not totally
sure about because I think he sucks is
maybe what black wants to play somehow
anyways so I'm not really sure about
this 55 hole still seems tense I mean
anyone's game here really anyone's game
hard to really say who is definitely
better here so we'll see what happens
this should go down to the wire I would
not be surprised by anything here our
chat is picking up again Nick asked our
nick says what a joy listening to
Alexander's unstoppable commentary
I agree Nick Nick also asked though why
do you guys call Evgeny Jack and not
Eugene actually that's something that I
always wanted to ask but was always
tried to ask I have an answer okay so I
know I'm the the guy who needs the
simple English name supposedly no he
simply goes by Jack around some people
evidently and around others he goes by
if guinea if you ask him yourself out on
the street he might give you one answer
it might give me the other he told me
Jack he told some of the people Jack so
that's what we call him Jack certain
boolean yeah I personally never knew
that until I came on the show that he's
called I promise you I would not just
make that up let's call Jack I don't
want to call me guinea Jack yeah I'm not
even sure how Jack in any way relates to
your guinea but it rhymes with the last
name I guess yeah just a bully yeah I
guess so yeah maybe yeah but anyway in
the game there's some exciting turn
around so okay I thought blacks should
probably go free six here but and then
after this maybe keep the tension with
like weeny seven or night of six but
black went for this obliging for the
trade and then he ended up taking with
the rook Quincy to maybe why could take
on g5 but of course that's always a
double edged moved to play with load
time II 6 rook F 1 GF EF and wide opened
the e-file but black also has lots of
planned here he comes
Knight g4 maybe it was better here to
play d5 here somehow just challenging
the center but okay he 194 he wants to
play for mate Queen h4 bridge 24 Danis
is a very aggressive player he likes to
play for me
I realized so if I ever play him I have
to be aware that he is out there going
for blood
so h3 Queen h4 but the question is is it
really mate you know if I play Bishop p1
rook f3 we'll see I think white has
enough resources here to stave off the
attack yeah but will we see the copy of
last game where Jack went for this
attack and black defendant encounter
attacked or will we see this time you
know
densha's Boris attack break through stay
tuned we'll find out very very soon yeah
so still nothing much is happening I
mean white is kind of defending against
the attack but black has some initiative
but at some point also white black needs
to not forget about this Queen side play
also becoming a factor later in the
tournament so black played the 54 very
natural move just setting up some ideas
in particular 93 might be a very looming
idea and now the best move for white
let's see if he finds it this night e2
and if 93 to take on d4 somehow and he
found it he found the move Knight e2
after which 93 probably doesn't work
because the Knight takes d4 Knight of 1
and and then there's some problems on
this long diagonal and let's see if
we're actually fine
see that variation entered the game now
dennis is thinking and he's concentrated
very deeply I'm not sure if he's like
that thrilled about this 92 move well
you mentioned some problems I mean the
problem is pretty concrete with the
bishop on c3 if it gets there because
then black is having to give up a heavy
piece to defend right yeah yeah so I
mean if you cannot go 93 then maybe the
special d4 move was just a mistake
possibly he just underestimated or
flat-out missed the move 92 I mean maybe
he can play move like e5 you know giving
up a bishop but then it really goes
completely out of control because you
know without a district then the black
king also becomes very weak and although
I think for better or worse Black has to
try
five here I mean cuz I don't see any
other really good move here but now
Janice is thinking and yeah he's kind of
okay so he went for 85 and that was a
very good move e5 is indeed a very
strong move which was played let's see
what would have happened if 93 let me
show it to you guys at them over at the
board so 93 would have been met by 960
for sure and now well if 96 of 196 and
suddenly White has a threat of simply
quintics of one Knights xb8 and bishops
III and you cannot stop all the three
threats rule and Black has no threats so
that was probably what Dennis calculated
and he realized that it wasn't working
and he played e5 very ambitious move
maybe black is too okay but it's very
very double-edged Knight 64 was correct
move probably now black has to decide
does he take the e pawn or the seaport I
don't know what's going on do you guys
know for me in the chat let us know I
mean this is a very complex game Raven
says perplexing indeed yeah it looks
like et XD 4 is actually quite promising
trying to open up the e-file
yeah actually maybe five was better than
I thought I mean all over maybe this
Bishop t45 combo was actually much
better than I originally thought because
black does open the e-file and maybe
gets the Foursquare control it's it's
still very double-edged and you took
with the e4 probably the correct choice
because C takes would be a big mistake
because of this this rook takes a 593
route 65 and there is no attack there's
nothing concrete there's some threats
but it's not concrete enough so each 64
was correct and now white played Bishop
d2 defending the three square and it was
possible bishop of two was more accurate
and now black absolutely has to bring
the rook to e8 bring his last piece into
the attack and I think if black actually
does that white actually has to solve
some very difficult questions because
his playing the Queen's that is too slow
and black has a lot of ideas like 93
Knight of six 94 93 and this could get
very very dangerous for white actually
so looks like Dennis's attack might
break through but he played nine of six
which also might be quite interesting
with the idea of meeting Queen takes a
5-wood Knight h5 also very interesting
idea maybe actually it's just as good I
thought rookie eight would be more
logical but this is certain also very
very very interesting and let's see what
happens so I'm sure he'll probably play
Knight h5 which he played and now black
actually wins the exchange by force
because there's no way to defend the
fork male black potentially threatening
a family fork and there's no way you can
defend everything right and even if you
go Bishop you won I think I move like
rook F 8 and then rook takes a 4 and it
will be yucky so white played King edge
to correct idea giving up that exchange
but still he has very good defensive
resources and potentially counter-plan
other sites so it's still anyone's game
and now they're really going down to the
wire so 93 was played a white went back
Queen g3 played quickly night and now
black will probably take on f1 and uh
let's see if you will do that or maybe
it's considering some I don't know it's
so kind of one which makes which makes a
lot of sense rook takes f1 and yeah now
probably black is somehow better but
it's still a very messy game you played
Queen g7 so Queen g7 was played I think
better move would have maybe been Queen
g6 offering a Queen's rate meeting this
with HG and then bringing the King in
the game and the spawn is very powerful
Queen sure 7 was played black is still
playing for attack but maybe at this
point it's not clear who's King is
actually safer so Queen f3 was played
rook e8 again Queen b7 was interesting
offering a queen sharain going it's 10
game rook rook e8 was played and now
white went for f5
25 check and now white will have to
decide where the king goes g1 rage
and this was some exciting chess right
here we're seeing indeed as Ruthie and
the chat says this game is the most
interesting thing I've seen in a while
to be honest we agree and white played
Bishop f4 not a move I anticipated
sacrificing their five point but maybe
he wants to take on g6 also interesting
maybe it's not as accurate but I mean
look they're playing pretty much almost
on delay at this point and you know in
such a complicated position this can
absolutely go either way
so black took on a five naturally I mean
what else and now he took on g6 but now
actually black is completely winning in
this position as long as black trades
Queens and plays rookies ooh I mean this
is actually a winning position for black
it just rolls out the red carpet for the
D pawn right yeah I mean you cannot
trade rooks really and not really sure
what white is hoping for in this
position maybe there's still some
last-minute counter play with a 5 B 6
but it looks like with perfect play this
should be winning for black so let's see
if any moves have been played it looks
like I see some moves been played on the
board but this is not updating this so
Queen takes of three was played rookie
two was played as expected and Bishop g3
was played defending but this is a now
black played h5 now is this legal move
it yeah I think it's fine because Haruka
5 is potentially met with not sure
actually what does he want yeah he
played rukka 5 yeah I'm not sure why he
play h5 actually maybe rook g8 was was
better just trying to promote this other
pawn but okay h5 was played rukka 5 he
still probably can go Rudy Aiden maybe
he's winning because this pawn on the D
file his weight so strong you might have
to give up the bishop for it so now
they're both down to one minute like
really exciting stuff like really a lot
of drama but what else will black play
what does he see the idea routine I'm
not sure what he'll go for in this
position he's thinking he needs to move
quickly because he's really getting long
time he played room d8 he played room ta
tat
you know best move in the position and
now if everything goes well he should be
able to convert this but of course you
know this is still so sharp that
anything can happen both players down to
about 40 seconds each this is so tense
and has there been moves made I think
jack is still thinking thus you want to
take h5 to c1 at 65 so many
possibilities so little time
go figure there's just such an exciting
part of the game you know these playoffs
so they gave us a treat really with
their fighting chests so there's been a
couple of my moves played Rock h5 King
Jade has been played I think at this
point we should just go to the yeah
let's go to the full board step three
the pond is our d3 rather than the pond
is being questioned bones being pushed
now you have to give up the bishop he
played before you have so there's no
other choice you have to get gether you
know give up the bishop and black I
think played rook F to you no not given
not quitting the right away but of
course white just plays here black look
like repeated moves a couple of times
and and now wise will go back probably
and now black will eventually go D to
probably at some point where worse what
else can he do he didn't go D - he
played king of seven
wow it's this interesting a5 was played
and now he should play D - I mean what
else he's not playing the - he played
rugby for Wow and now white can play B 6
+ b 6 actually draws and he but he
missed it he played Bishop g5 it's a
mistake they were white had a brilliant
solution here b6 takes takes takes and
then b7 and he Queens first but they
have no time so let's see how how this
has been played out so did sue you know
Bishop takes did to rook takes did
Soraka g5 king of six Russia eight black
is completely winning here but it's
still anyone's game
rook f8 now the rooks come comes to g4
and and now he won another pawn and it
looks like yeah looks like black will
convert
he has an extra rope basically the
bishops were traded and yeah they're
playing basically on the delay but yeah
it's it looks like yeah he'll just get
rid of all the pawns and we'll be able
to avenge the wind the game now all of
whites left us with two pawns on G and F
file but yeah this should be a very easy
technical task for Dennis burrows rubgy
one rube comes behind Kings come comes
in jack is still fighting somehow
desperately trying to survive this but
probably will not manage Russia fives
still trying to keep still not so easy
to win
believe it or not this I mean I remember
one game rook against two rooks against
rope with some point which he didn't you
know some strong Jim wasn't able to win
everyone please remember that Burroughs
has to win the force in our veggetti
yeah and you know this is just getting
so tense it's incredible they're playing
and remember there's I don't know if
anyone can claim a 50 mo o g4 g4 was
winning g4 was waiting for white rook
takes g4 okay five oh wow there was
there is an opportunity for for white
too so come back but just as quickly as
it appeared it disappeared yeah it's
incredible
so White's still holding the position
somehow King edge three oh and Jack just
saw some time oh we lost one time most
on time and this position might still
you know be not so easy to win but of
course it's probably eventually winning
and now we're gonna go toward mageddon
2y victories wow what a drama look
Barros has suddenly some pep in his step
again you can see there on the camera so
here's what we're gonna do the arbiters
might cover in Sam choy get in the
tournament Hall will determine somehow
maybe I know Tony Rich's here as well
one of them is going to have a drawing
of lots and we're gonna have one game
winner take all five minutes versus four
minutes arm again I know it just to show
you guys where white mist is a big
opportunity yeah let's say it was a
summer around here you know this was all
like good by both sides and suddenly
here
um yeah no not here yet and a few more
moves yeah here suddenly black made a
huge Oh mister put the King in the wrong
square and if white somehow
instinctively found she for he would
have got his drawer he would have won
the tournament because after this you
just check and then you win this and
then you don't even take the rook
because of mate but you just keep
checking and there's no way to avoid the
perpetual so that would have been
incredible safe for white like an
incredible chance here but he's playing
on delay he had like two seconds per
move and he naturally instinctively just
kept checking and and then you know he
lost on time you mentioned to keep
checking but if if the black King runs
down onto the first rank well and at
that point you have to stay near the
Jeep rook because then white takes it
right yeah so that was that was an
incredible moment here right here
dramatic moment when g4 was there for
the taking for for Stan Bullock but alas
not meant to be and now you know we're
gonna see another treat an Armageddon
game between these two great fighters
and I see we just changed the wording
there get excited everyone Armageddon
time it's it's ready it's ready this
isn't def leppard it's chess it's even
better so do you think that Jack even
realizes at this point that he had G
form no I don't actually think so
there's no way because I iron I know
that when I've played these blitz events
and when somebody will tell me I had
something I'm like what but but so yeah
I doubted blitz position existed first
split second in time so seconds for
movie I it's it's I don't I don't think
so
so I these drawing of lots for big
events you know the US Championship this
year it was at the st. Louis Zoo and the
players all drew a number that was on
the bottom of a stuffed animal because
it was the zoo like really cute stuff
for this I I think it might be as simple
as pick a hand
in one hand as white and one hand as
black and this is important because
white gets five minutes black gets four
minutes but the trade-off here is that
if the black gets draw ads if it's a
draw then black gets the nod it's as if
black one yeah which one would you
rather have
um I think it would be depending on who
I'm playing I miss them but I usually
take white in such a situation because I
think you know five against four is a
pretty substantial advantage without any
delay of course right it's without delay
right I don't remember reading that
there actually it's a without delay well
if it's without delay and it was with
delay I think it's just miss without
delay I would definitely take the five
because you know first of all I'm white
I can choose the opening or gonna play
for initiative I can do a lot of things
I can try to flag so I think it's a very
big advantage five minutes for me
personally I usually take white and such
a station if it's like bullets like that
but that's just me and I also depends on
who I'm playing as well if I'm playing
someone who is known to be very very
saltless black with very good repertoire
then I might as well take black but I
think it's the pencils all home playing
there you can see the arbiters in the
tournament hall maybe giving the players
a few minutes rest here before their
heart rates increase once again I wonder
if what happened to my heart rate I I
didn't even take my monitor it's just
such a busy day for me it's you know the
funny effect here
you know Tony rich has been the
executive director of the st. Louis
chess club since the very beginning and
Sam choy cat they're a national arbiter
yeah he threw me out of a tournament
Hall once so good guys Wow
well anyway I wonder how long until the
next game because if we have a few
minutes I'd love to tell you about some
upcoming events we have at the st. Louis
chess club you know this summer is gonna
be yet again another summer of chess and
it kicks off in a big way the summer
chess classic starts on June 18th it's
gonna be the strongest seasonal classic
we've ever had with a seventy-five
thousand dollar prize fund that's huge
guys this is gonna be an amazing event
this is going to be next level 2700
level tournament I'm here and so stay
tuned guys this is going to be a lot of
fun
and yet that
well that'll be at us chest champs calm
after that of course croatia grande
chest or the second stop on this year's
grand chest or it will be classical
chests all 12 full time grand chests or
competitors will be playing in croatia
and the points are gonna be weighted
they're gonna be worth the most and
who's gonna be adding on to what we just
saw in Cote d'Ivoire Magnus Carlsen
coming down on top in that event with a
13-point advantage just straight out of
the gig that's gonna start on June 26
Croatia and then of course the US senior
junior and girls championship takes
place right here at the st. Louis chess
club starting on July 11th with the
addition of the senior tournament it's
the first time ever but let's turn our
attention to what we see what we see at
the board and Alex do you have the third
game open yet yeah I think so is it this
one it we might need to put it should be
round twelve it'd be the last one we
have oh yeah maybe you maybe is it
upstairs here or let's just open it back
up again
we can see the play and as you could see
both players are smiling and just how
can you not and this yeah so such a nice
battle and and Jack ended up choosing
white and they went for a night of three
night of six are very quite opening and
this time Dennis was playing very solid
line because at this point he's happy
with a draw naturally so he doesn't need
to go for any complications but maybe
actually he should have just stayed true
to his style because that's serve them
very well playing very aggressive in
this tournament however even this is
kind of unbalanced I mean the system is
playing for that basically both sides
are playing a Grich strategical game
wide is clearly playing on the Queen
side black maybe at some point is gonna
play on the Kings side here maybe in the
center so all in all looks like you know
just a pretty normal type battle and you
know we'll see what happens and again I
usually like White's chances and these
kind of things but of course you know
Dennis is just need to draw but at the
same time as we've seen so far it's not
so easy to get a draw even if you want
it even with white so drawing on demand
is not always so easy but winning on
demand could be even tougher but so far
dennis is doing just fine he has a very
solid position playing relatively
quickly ninety four very logical move
trying to exchange the Knights
simplifying the game so maybe White has
a very slight pool but it's probably
close to equal so white played e3 and
black played a very ambitious move there
should be four you can also go up ninety
six back claiming that he maybe you
created some weaknesses but Bishop g4
certainly very logical white plate of
three he wanted to do so we can assume
that he traded on v3 and he's gonna
probably gonna go Bishop a5 or something
he went Bishop e6
it looks like blacks fine
so let's see what else what can white
play for I mean what would I even do
here maybe I'll play ok so he took on c6
and does he wanna just go Queen b7 or
Queen b6 I see oh yeah but after Oaks c8
I think black is just very comfortable I
don't know why he went for the
simplification what he needs to win okay
so he went for a four that was his idea
but now maybe black actually should
abandon the idea of trading Queens and
try to go for an attack but he played 97
the most simple approach but now
actually that's actually the big blunder
because why has a very strong move
Knight b5 which just wins a pawn so
white spots that he gets a big advantage
so 97 was just a huge blunder
overlooking his opponent's idea but he
missed it he played 94 he might he
played 94 and now it's not so clear it's
actually back to normal again from black
so very big missed opportunity here for
black so black played Bishop f8 solid
move white play Knight g5 still
certainly some initiative but now black
is completely fine here he took on he
took on a4 maybe Bishop f5 is also okay
but now they're moving very quickly
lightning speed which is natural for a
blitz game and yeah this position is
still kind of double-edged but black
should be doing relatively ok black has
a lot of activity black has not bad
pieces and certainly the gun still go
either way but black is not losing his
time advantage Rock f2 black is actually
now only behind 30 seconds which is huge
for time control like this so black went
45 trying to blunt in the bishop on g2
very logical and let's see what white
tries here white played Bishop c3 which
makes a lot of sense bringing the bishop
to a long diagonal and let's see what
black tries here now
yeah blog played rock a3 keeping the
ropes on the board because his rook on
a3 is a very active piece so no reason
to trade that off
and what did white play he's probably
gonna play rook seats or something like
that yeah he played Roxy - and there's
been some moves rook I said Oh Luke a7
was a huge mistake because now after a
CD Bishop g4 suddenly there's some big
problems on the seventh and eighth ranks
but white again miss this opportunity
played quickly king of - king of seven
kingi - just bringing the king of the
game very natural but now black has once
again consolidated and there's some more
moves played Bishop f3 rotates ooh rugby
Tzu okay three Bishop c4 c5 and here
again black has just completely fine
Bishop c3 dc-dc Bhishma six and this has
simplified into a position which is very
very close to a draw and now the only
question is whether white can flag black
or somehow really just trick him in a
very confusing manner but it looks like
black is objectively very very close to
a draw in this position so - a very big
missed opportunities for white but
that's of course understandable for a
blitz game that if indeed it refers
draws and he gets the nod he is the
champ so now our even white lost his
time advantage at this point you know
white is not even up on time anymore
which is kind of huge so now two rooks
two pairs of rooks can't be traded and
now black and play 98-96 transfer
transferring the night he decided to go
from where concrete line e5 97 which is
also perfectly fine good tonight on e5
and no problems whatsoever and at this
point I just don't see how black should
lose this game if anyone's better it's
black with this very strong night
so Rugby six was played going for some
desperate activity which makes a lot of
sense locate two and a Knight g4 was
played that was very strong creating
counter play with the night Hiroki six
was played King the now he's deciding
how to get out of the check probably
king bee seven is the simplest and he's
still thinking maybe he's thinking about
King g8 or King f8 but he better play
quickly because time is very very
important at this moment he chose she
went for King d7 which is completely
fine white played h3 and black played
night of two and oh oh wow look what
just happened
bishop why blood just made a terrible
blunder night six h3 and completely
blundering this check and now white is
completely winning oh wow what a
terminal of events when black was like
this close to just getting the draw
you know in the simplest possible matter
society huh huge blunder just occurs out
of nowhere man is nervous a very big
part of chess just like when you that's
why you can never relax at any moment a
disaster could strike in chess and now
black is completely new losing now it's
just a matter of whether he wins in time
but of course 57 seconds is plenty good
enough to win this kind of position
against anybody and yeah I feel so bad
for Dennis he was so close and there's a
handshake jackson buyuk with the fork
heard round the world
he puts an end to the tournament he is
the 2019 st. Louis norm Congress Grand
Master norm field
champion Wow so blood white missed two
big chances to beg get a big advantage
early on and that just when it was
already looking like the game was
definitely heading towards a draw
suddenly he had this third big chance
and that one he did not miss and after
that that was all she wrote it's just so
painful so tragic shoe in such a simple
position when I did bring up the board
here if we can just so we can see this
post game analysis hold on yeah
there we go yeah it's just such a tragic
blunder night's xh3
just Bishop e6 at the worst possible
moment I just feel so bad for Dennis but
you know what justice could be a cruel
game and what to do but I don't even
like I don't think I agree with the idea
of playing h5 I don't see why he did
that creating more weaknesses why not
just go king of six king of five and you
know why create new weaknesses create
problems for yourself
h5 just was a step in the wrong
direction allowing some would be sick so
now he has to already calculate some
lines up and then night of two is still
fine and then after ninety one let's say
rookie six okay just two it's still kind
of okay but in this cameand and that was
all she wrote perfect stuff from jackson
bully AK and you know or rather so
imperfect it's perfect to watch as a
viewer and while we're waiting on our
victory lap interview with evgeny
stamboli AK for those of you in the chat
there you go i someone asked I can't
find the comedy more they said
statistically with this five verses for
Armageddon who tends to win and I would
think that they that's the balance right
it's supposed to be 50/50 probably it
should be yes I think that's why it
again I think it depends on who you play
ultimately but I still kind of feel like
white should have better practical
chance and even here where white did not
you know really play in the best way
still it's kind of hard to be on the
defensive all the time right so I I
would still say I would take black more
often than white especially without
delay I mean I would take white instead
of black without too late what the delay
it would be like more close maybe yeah
it would be a tough question to answer
and as far as Orion Murphy he asked I
couldn't find any stance on Armageddon
percentages and I think probably that's
because they're not rated so it's kind
of like if you're not following the
tournament directly or recall that there
was an Armageddon showdown at the end I
mean I don't know where you could look
to fight
that pool of Armageddon blitz games I
mean yeah it's um I don't know maybe you
have to just find some YouTube videos of
recent ones but I'm sure there's been
many before YouTube which probably have
been lost in shuffle right well let's
let's start this game over I don't know
if you'll want to look at it or the
preceding ones but we have Jack ready to
come in the champ is ready for his
interview so I'll be back in just a bit
to close the show yeah sounds good so
yeah this game started like in a very
slow manner 23 is kind of very d4 is
more common but then it gets more
theoretical and probably you know jock
wanted to kind of just keep pieces on
the board it makes some sense there will
be one this is a pretty natural plan and
and here in this position the big
moments were right around here when well
first of all here black should have
realized that okay at this point after a
four suddenly the tide has changed and
actually the Queen is out of play and
after a move like Bishop h3 Black is
suddenly the one who is a bit better but
97 was played Queen takes rook takes 90
and now here was where the first
opportunity was missed with 95 but
anyway we'll talk now to the winner of
the tournament in Jackson Bullock so
Jack what an exciting playoff I mean so
much drama all over the place so
congratulations on pulling it all how do
you feel now I think yeah I mean I feel
pretty good it's always nice to be in a
tournament but I think they I mean all
of the games were pretty bad like I
don't know I think I get like at the end
that here blunder tonight yeah but you
know somebody at some point has to get
lucky yeah feel like that right the
problem is that it's so hard to play
blitz after a classical game very hard
yeah yeah especially right after not
even a day after but right off yeah this
was basically like blitz I mean 10
minutes 2 seconds delay pretty much it
very quickly becomes like like blitz
yeah so what do you think were the main
critical moments maybe in this game or
maybe is
the previous games I mean in the first
games I got a very bad position of those
opening you think in the first game you
got a bad position I thought I thought
you were kind of doing okay where did
you think you you were you were doing
badly Oh probably like in a couple of
moves from here yeah so here there are
definitely a lot of interesting
possibility yeah maybe there's east six
first made some sense but even here I
mean well I think if you go is six you
might still be okay but c6 yeah what I
think I guess there's this one big
moment I was wondering if you saw that
they played rugby one what was your plan
here from day one mm-hm
that wasn't sure maybe b5 yeah b5 and
then let's say you take take a few times
take and then just play for compensation
right yeah yeah I mean it was my
position because I mean at least I'm not
losing right away yeah you're not losing
right away and here okay you might be a
little bit better but I mean their
positions virus solids for a heart to
break through but I mean so me it looked
like that was his best chance to really
get an advantage in this game I didn't
really see where where else you could
have where else did you think you might
be worse I mean I sing only here at the
beginning but then I get a good position
ya know here you're doing very well
yeah and after this where do you think
you know you like what moment did you
think that you already have a very good
chance to win this game that you already
taken over the initiative like here he
got to go Quinn's history in this
position I mean trying to take
everything on b5 I would go look she ate
and they would threaten everything and
make it so on it would be a draw yeah
but after he played Bishop g-body floor
was a very for yeah here is plan but
very risky even here Bishop f6 looks
like you still have position under
control but yeah he played for a rare
risky plan and I think he underestimated
the fact that this Bishop at some point
really gets into the game and this was a
very brilliant maneuver bishop f8 before
just activating that piece you know and
suddenly black is just much better and
this attack was a desperate attack but
it never really worked the Bishop d7 was
also very accurately yeah because I kept
to defend a six month yeah because H
exactly and now as you'll see later on
you know the key point was that now he
six was protected and now one last
accurate move Bishop c8 and then there's
just no defense against this and the
rest is kind of matter of technique I
mean he went for some desperate play
here but you know I was always very much
easily winning okay you have to be a
little bit careful but yes this is
winning and then in the second game I
want what what what went into your
decision to play I I try to miss some
technical issue a little bit here oh
it's not quite loading
oh no no sorry oh yeah okay there there
we go yeah so yeah the second game what
may went in your to your decision of
let's say playing Knight c3 instead of
e4 or g5 yeah I don't know for some
reason I tend to play super solid but I
mean of course it never works out yeah
it's right if you tried to play solid I
mean your opponent's will get even more
chance comfortable game and more time
yeah so that was I was also not sure
about this kind of approach it looked
like it was solid but but also black got
a comfortable position where you had
play for a win without will taking so
much risk yeah and basically we got a
very interesting fighting game which was
chances for both sides there's certain
lots of critical moments I don't want to
keep you too long maybe 95 here yeah it
should be played yes that was my idea
like I wanted to play Queen b3 Bishop
Evans on 95 but I just means if he can
go Bishop Jade on e6 and yeah there
should be eight yeah exactly that was a
nice harmony for him and this is also
kind of double-edged I mean maybe both
sides could play a bit better but yeah I
think the next critical moment was
somewhere around here where he found a
very nice move e5 yeah very nice idea
you know of course 93 there was Knight
64 was sure yeah I say 5 Knight takes
IDI that was also accurate yeah maybe
Bishop f2 should have been more accurate
yeah maybe but I have to play a fossil
yeah this point yeah it's very hard
practical
I think it was actually a good decision
to give up the exchange from practical
standpoint of view but um but why didn't
you play let's say King g1 yeah I don't
know I was afraid of Queen e2 ah but
actually Queen e2 it's just yeah I can
just move my bishop you just move the
bishop yeah yeah I didn't say well you
but even if you take and then the rook F
2 is so bad I guess yeah it's kind of
bad yeah yeah but still have some
chances better than the game yeah
because before looks like it was losing
yeah from this point on it was probably
losing I mean there were some chances
odds and yeah they broke yeah but you
for yeah yeah you you realized that
after did someone earlier did did you
see I kind of saw it but then I had to
second so I just made a move oh I see
yeah yeah you know what Jack is talking
about of course is this so actually I
was wrong I thought you wouldn't realize
right after that you had this
opportunity but it turns out I was wrong
you did see right away but ok and you
know it's cause it was quite random in
this position yeah and then this
position and then this game was yeah
this was one of these young you just
have to both players can play have to
play quickly and yeah the critical
moment was I guess somewhere around here
you know I had to create Queens right
after rook c8 I had to take one c7 right
away because here he can go seven but
actually it turned out very good for you
because you have an amazing opportunity
here 95 you didn't say yeah so 94 and
now it's kind of a you know hard to win
equalist position but here it actually
you had another very nice opportunity C
takes followed by Bishop d4 oh maybe
this is like harder to find it in blitz
but amazingly not you actually penetrate
but yeah what you played is very logical
bringing the king in the game and yeah
this I expected this to be a draw it's
very simple but for some reason he
started creating himself a lot of
problems and
yeah man I thought 98-96 should be the
simplest yeah and this is also totally
okay but now h5 I think it's very
unnecessary you know creating weaknesses
and now actually in time pressure there
is some ways to confuse him and this
rookie six was a very nice move it took
some time of a squad cool it's just so
confusing move for him and and then you
know of course you know at some point
you know nerves played a factor and
tension and you came away with the
clutch win so it's as I've said many
times in these kind of playoffs nerves
make the big difference and whoever
blunders second-to-last yes yes that's
what happened ultimately but
congratulations on a naturalist very
very deserved win because you know I
always believe that whoever gets
fortunate in the end you know probably
worked very hard before the tournament
for that's probably done a lot of right
things before that to earn it so
congratulations on this great success
and I wish you all the best in your
upcoming tournaments thank you alright
so that was Jackson Bullock our winner
of the tournament here with us and that
pretty much wraps up this very exciting
day of you know both in the round nine
last round and then we had a very
exciting playoff which really went down
to the wire and unfortunately for black
for Janish tragic blunder decided at all
so yeah I'm speechless at this point I
mean what a tournament what a turn turn
a turn of events I'm probably sweating
more than even if I would have been
playing this playoff commentating this
exciting turn of events so any
last-minute thoughts then Alex it has
been a really great photo finish here
going to the latest possible stage of
playoffs and what I'd like to do is well
congratulate all the players first of
all Keaton Kira who was the champion of
the International master section but
also let's take a look at our
Grandmaster norm section the final
standings if we have them it
the tie it's been settled but at the end
of regulation here's where we stand we
have from the bottom up Casa Corley
brandon jacobson taunted by bhajami and
andrew hong brian Escalante those five
players leave with six hundred dollars
each
even though Escalante hog and Opera ami
had finished better six hundred dollars
each their prize now the top half joel
bonala and JJ a lemur and a walk away
with $750 they tied for fourth place
four and a half points each and
unfortunately for JJ he was the lone
Grandmaster in the trio that came in
that was not in the playoff but still a
fine performance finishes even and then
the top three international master
Justin Wang came very close to earning a
norm but it was not to be he leaves with
a grand and then our two top finishers
Grandmaster Dennis burrows blunders in
the very end in Armageddon and he leaves
with $1,500 and after playoffs
we know that the champion the undisputed
champion of the Grand Master norm
section of the norm Congress is Evgeniy
Jack stem bully ACK he leaves with
$2,000 okay well this has been a lot of
fun Alex yeah I've really had a good
time and this wheel keeps in motion here
at the Chess Club we have some big
upcoming events before we sign off that
you need to know about coming up next is
the summer chess classic it's June 18
through the 28th a little bit different
this time seventy-five thousand dollar
prize fund the strongest one yet and a
little bit of a different format in the
past we have seen 10 player round robins
single round robins now we're going to
have three fields three sets of six
players a B and C it's a double
round-robin it starts on June 18th and
then of course the grand chest tour
rolls through Croatia for a classical
chess that begins on June
26 and then after that a big trio of
tournaments a summer favorite of the st.
Louis chess club the junior girls junior
and yes the brand new senior Chess
Championships and that goes from July
10th to the 21st the first round is on
July 11th the seniors I think will give
them top billing when it's all said and
done that's gonna be the highest rated
of the fields and like I said earlier
we're gonna party like it's the u.s.
championship of 10-15 years it's like
the yours championship of the early
2000s all over again yeah I think the
rule is 55 and up I think that was the
colors are not 50 no I think it's 50 is
it 50 because I know I think Alex
Fishbein I know I mentioned on Facebook
he's playing and I know he just turned
50 and also Alex shovel off is I believe
is playing and he's all starting younger
than 55 he's just over 50 so I'm pretty
sure it's supposed to be 50 well
hopefully they're not cheating the
system and you expose them yeah let's go
with all 50 and up no I that's probably
what it is it's gonna be a lot of fun I
got shouldn't call settle they seen a
lot of these players again Hey
July 11th tune in u.s. chess champs calm
it's gonna be an awesome fun busy summer
but I think it's time for dinner Alex we
do a long time we've we've earned that
you know it's been an overtime today so
hey it happens we want to thank Tammy
Hyde who was watching the stream making
sure it didn't drop our world's greatest
B team Danny Machuca the technical
director of this event switching the
cameras for you Isaac France is audio
and graphics with the levels you know
and also Eric Mosel the designer of the
show's graphics awesome jobs all the way
around alex has been a pleasure thank
you Ben you same to you likewise it's
been a pleasure working with you and
hopefully many more to come
yeah absolutely he's Grandmaster and
residents the hardest working man in
chess Alexander Lenny I don't know about
quite about that I know hey Jerry during
this event that's don't miss it let's go
with that
my name is Ben Simon and until the
summer classic we say so long from the
show me
stay
[Music]
you
you